[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
I'll leave it up to you okay good
morning folks this is uh what is it
episode 202 202 with Dinesh D'Souza a
special guest here today
somebody that's uh loved by uh
conservatives and hated by the opposite
side these uh many would call him the
controversial figure he's got a lot to
say about uh the election with the
recent documentary that came out 2 000
mules which I had a chance to watch uh
his uh most uh favorite name he's been
using the last I want to say three days
is a man named Paul maybe we'll talk
about this Paul character today Paul
Pelosi I think you've been uh tweeting
uh friendly things about him lately and
there's a bunch of other things with his
resume we've I think you and I uh
do we did a podcast or an interview
together a year and a half ago and it
did very well got a few million views
the audience loved it so we have them
back so anyways having said that thank
you so much for being on a podcast hey
it's a pleasure great to be back and
sure enough yeah I think we did I did a
film called Hillary's America we did a
podcast together and then a few months
later I went on and looked on YouTube
and it was like four million hits I was
like wow this guy must be important yeah
this guy's doing something with his life
can I say one thing you're doing
something you said he's loved he's hated
I don't think he's hated because I think
maybe some of the content you do yeah or
some of the you know obviously these are
post movies he knows how to poke he true
but there is something about your
demeanor that that makes you very
likable regardless if you don't agree
with you because you're respectful
you're intelligent I know obviously
people on the left are not a fan of you
but you are a likable guy from what I
could tell I don't know we might get in
a fight today I hope not but I will say
say that you do things with class and
with grace for the most part and so I I
don't like when people use the word hate
I think I've you know
let me let me clarify yes he's hated by
the left yes okay
thank you for that correction Adam no he
is but he's a likable guy but he's Faded
by the left correct and that's
intentional that's intentional because
sometimes you got to do that to get the
other side to be riled up and you know
make up their minds about where they're
at but we got a lot of things to talk
about because also just this week about
your 2000 mules documentary I saw
something on New York Times WAP poll
that you know someone came out suing all
that stuff matter of fact why don't we
just get right into it if that's what
we're going to be doing and and what
we'd want to do today then I since we've
already done an interview and people
know your background I just wanted
topics with you so what topical topics
economy politics midterms Kanye Kyrie
Biden all of that stuff but let's first
go into 2000 mules so for some people
that don't know if you don't mind uh I
had a chance to watch it yesterday I
know Charlie Kirks in it Dennis prager's
in it uh I want to say almost everybody
was in it I've had on the podcast before
but once you take a minute and share
with everybody what was in 2000 meals
yeah so dude Utah meals is a is a movie
about election fraud and um it's not
kind of what you expect because right
after the 2020 election uh people raised
all kinds of issues they said oh isn't
it strange that Trump won these
Bellwether counties and he still won and
still lost the election
um wasn't it strange that the the
counting and all the key States seemed
to stop at the same time and Trump was
winning the next morning whoa It's all
the opposite direction now these are
anomalies not an anomaly is something
strange but by itself it doesn't prove
anything because there could be a
reasonable explanation
and uh so I stayed out of the election a
fraud debate for over a year
and then I was approached by a couple of
people who run an organization called
true the vote
uh and they they told me you know we
found an ingenious way to look at this
issue that no one has done before and uh
it's a combination of two things one is
cell phone Geo tracking which is of
course today a reliable technology used
by law enforcement used by the CIA used
by the CDC to monitor people's social
distancing
it's the tracking of your phone it's the
same technology that if you come to you
know go to Naples on vacation you get
off the plane they tell you the weather
is going to be really nice in Naples
well how they know you're there they're
tracking your phone and the other
um the second line of evidence is the
surveillance video of the states
themselves so a number of states not all
but some install surveillance video
outside these mail and dropboxes
amazingly a year later no one had gone
back and looked at the footage it's
almost like having surveillance on a
bank there's the charge the bank's been
robbed but nobody bought it to go look
on the video so true the vote said look
we're going to show you some of the cell
phone Geo tracking we're going to show
you some of the video and and when I
looked at that I said to myself this is
a evidence of a completely different
caliber than I've seen before
um I don't know yet what it proves but
this is a way to go back you know we
were moving away from the election
this is a way to go back and look at the
actual cell phone movements of people
who are going to multiple drop boxes 10
10 or more 10 or more drop boxes now
remember that when you're talking about
a Dropbox we're not talking about the
mailbox somebody has a reason to go to a
mailbox many times right you can say I I
mailed my mortgage on Monday and then I
mailed my utility bill on Tuesday I
wrote my mom on Wednesday but a ballot
Dropbox you only have one reason to go
put ballots in it so if some guy's going
to 10 or more drop boxes it's hard to
think of a good explanation for why they
would do that so if you can use cell
phone tracking to find people who are
going in a short period right after the
election the few days after the election
to 10 or more drop boxes that needs to
be investigated then let's just say that
we find you know Patrick your cell phone
you've gone to 10 or more dropboxes
and there are a couple of those drop
boxes that have video
so let's just say that we know that by
from your cell phone that you on
Election Day or the day before the
election were at all these drop boxes
and we actually know the time you got
there because it's from your phone so
now we go look on the video and there's
Patrick that David and what is he doing
you can see him on video he's putting
ballots into the box one two three four
five so this is evidence who has access
to this so the the states took the video
you can obtain the video through public
records that's how true the vote got it
you can get it there's not a person in
the country has said that's not the real
this is available to everybody if I
wanted to go get it tomorrow I could get
it yes okay perfect absolutely Freedom
of Information right that's why I'm
asking similarly with the cell phone Geo
tracking it's not known to people but
you can go now and buy the data let's
just say Atlanta the city of Atlanta you
can buy the data from October 1 to
November 8th Election Day 2020 right of
every cell phone in a What's called the
geofenced area you draw the map app and
they'll give you that data you can buy
it and of course you need Specialists to
do a the proper kind of Investigation
but you can use that data to confirm or
undermine what we've been saying in this
film so that's the so the film operates
on those two lines of evidence and
that's what makes it remarkable that so
many people have tried to sort of
dismiss or debunk the film it's okay to
debate the film and it's okay to debate
the significance of what you're seeing
but to pretend like it's not relevant to
election fraud seems to me foolish so
let me ask you so here's a few questions
that would get me to think if there is
fraud going on out of all the videos
that were recording was there any City
or any area that wouldn't give you the
recording or was not somehow some way
available to see yes so a number of
areas did not take video which is
actually very bad because think of it
number one we live in a country and at a
time when technology is cheap uh every
Mall every parking lot is under video
right any is there any good reason not
to put a camera on a Dropbox how many
places were there was a lot of places
that was the necessary places the
majority of places did not have video at
all and they basically used the excuse
of covet they basically said oh you know
yeah we should but we never got around
to it so the only a few places that did
video and and even those places fight
you when you try to get the video they
don't make it easily available why not
um so this is right away a clue that
they're trying to block you from
watching what's on the video how long
have we been recording videos uh in
where people go and drop off their
ballots how long have we been recording
the history of recording videos
well here's the thing
it has been known for over I mean over
100 years that the vast majority of
election fraud occurs with absentee and
mail-in ballots and the reason is
obvious if you go into vote you're there
all these people are there you're behind
a curtain they give you one ballot you
fill it out you drop it off you leave
there's just so much there's not much
you can do with Shenanigans in fact if
you tried them they'd stop you like if I
were to say if I go into vote and I tell
them listen I have an urgent appointment
let me take my ballot and my brother
will bring it back and give it to you
filled out they'd be like no way okay
it's ridiculous right there we're not
going to allow that right of course but
think about it that's exactly what
happens with the mailing ballot they
have these voter rolls and the voter
rolls by the way are notoriously
inaccurate by that I mean Americans move
all the time let's say you move three
times over the last 10 years your name
is going to be on all those places that
you lived and no one's taken it off even
though the DMV knows you moved the tax
people know you moved everybody knows
you moved but nobody tells the election
people so you now can vote three times
and nobody will know the difference and
and if they send out a mail-in ballot
three Patrick Bet David Malin ballots
are going to all the places that you
live it's not all that difficult to get
your hands on these ballots so what I'm
getting at is there's the opportunity
with mail-in ballots to have fraud now
what made 2020 different was that for
the first time the mail-in ballot which
used to be a tiny part of the election
became a huge part of the election so
it's almost like the opportunity for
fraud multiplied greatly so so then if
they did that let's just say the claims
of there was uh above and beyond voter
fraud than usual we always have voter
fraud it's not a new thing it's
something that's been going on since day
one and this happens in all elections a
big one just took place recently in a
country that has a great soccer team but
aside from that uh uh uh with this voter
fraud that we're talking about but to
say that this is somehow some way more
than and above and beyond because of
covid so then that means midterm
shouldn't be above and beyond because
covet's pretty much gone we don't have
the shutdown right so 20 22 midterms
next week should be pretty fair as well
as 2024 because that covet excuse cannot
be used is that a fair question well
it's a little complex I would say yes I
have made no claims of the 2022 election
is in danger in any way although I do
think part of the reason for that is
that 20 million people have seen our
film and they're more aware of what
these problems are 20 million people
have seen I've seen 2 000 meals yes so
it's it's been out there it's it's the
most successful political documentary of
the last 10 years actually to be honest
since my first film which was called
2016 Obama's America that was the
previous kind of record holder this is
number two
um Michael Moore is the record holder in
documentary political documentaries of
all time but his films were made a long
time ago he's not making good films
today it's like Roger
Roger and me was actually quite a small
film but it was very well done it put
him on the map his big film was
Fahrenheit 911. so yeah Fahrenheit 911
is the number one political documentary
of all time my Obama film is number two
this is gonna be a competitor for number
three do you and Michael Moore ever
collaborate debate discuss anything you
guys any of any relationship with each
other no we don't we've actually had a
little bit of like a social media
skirmishing but but it would actually be
really fun yeah why wouldn't you guys
have a conversation debate I don't know
maybe maybe you get someone that likes
hosting debates and figure that out I
don't know I'm just throwing that out
there to the atmosphere I would be open
to it I think it would do I mean we
could even do a Vegas or do if we did a
public event it would it would do well I
agree really fun to do I know a guy that
might be interested in hosting something
like that so yeah we'll keep you posted
well coming back to you know coming back
to 2020 2020 was an anomalous election
um in and um and uh what I want to make
a distinction between voter fraud and
election fraud and here's the
distinction if one guy says you know
um I'm gonna vote three times or I'm
going to vote on behalf of my father he
died last year but nobody knows it so
he's still on the rolls I'm going to
vote for him that's not going to tip an
election voter fraud is different than
election fraud so election fraud is
organized
I'll give you an historical example in
in 1864 we had a lot of mail-in ballots
in this country for an obvious reason
all the soldiers were at the on the
battlefield so they couldn't show up to
vote so they use mail-in ballots
and sure enough a bunch of
um Democrats in New York said let's rig
the election against Lincoln New York at
that time New York City was heavily
Democratic and so what they did is they
intercepted these soldiers ballots they
would steam them open change the vote
from Lincoln to McClellan or they would
vote the soldiers ballots who didn't
know they voted so there was a mail-in
ballot fraud scheme made possible by the
the peculiarity of the Civil War
so fast forward to 2020 2020 was sort of
the same unstable environment in which
election fraud became a real possibility
now what two thousand meals alleges is
this it alleges that there were these
left-wing non-profits in the inner city
we're not talking about throughout the
country but we're talking about key
Battleground States the urban areas
now these left-wing non-profits got a
huge infusion of liberal cash right
before the election which alone is kind
of odd because non-profit organizations
are not supposed to be involved in
partisan electioneering they all have
this tax status call 501c3 they're
supposed to they can they can
generically say guys we it's a civic
duty to vote but they can't say you got
to vote for Biden or you got to vote for
Trump they can't do that but they get
all this money and then we see on the
video you can actually see it these
mules show up with backpacks and we use
the term mule because of you know human
trafficking or sex trafficking this is
ballot trafficking the mules don't come
up with the ballots they're given these
backpacks of ballots to go drop off in
all the dropboxes and um but they get
them from these left-wing non-profits
the left-wing nonprofits go here's the
backpack the mule then goes on a kind of
a route and the reason that they go to
many dropboxes is kind of obvious if
they go to one dropbox and put in 500
votes then all the other dropboxes will
have 40 or 50 votes but suddenly 500
show up here people will be like what's
going on so they're instructed not to do
that diversification diversification in
the investment world I get it okay and
and again the combination of the cell
phone tracking and seeing them on video
is very suggestive now the debunkers
there's plenty of debunkers of our movie
and some of them have said you know Geo
tracking doesn't really work and you
can't really pinpoint these people going
to drop boxes and some of them have said
well you haven't shown us the same mule
in multiple drop boxes so there are
lines of criticism that I want to
acknowledge although I think I've
adequately I've been answering them on
my podcast I answer them in my book so
this is the debate that's been going so
so you know in the documentary it starts
off if if you guys haven't seen it
starts off Dennis Prager saying I'm I'm
not uh part of the camp I don't believe
this happened I don't believe this is
real I I think 2020 election was real
and all this stuff and you know Biden
won it fair and square and then at the
end you know it ends in a complete
different way where he's like you know
if this is what I just saw right now
everybody needs to see everybody needs
to realize what's going on anyway so so
that's that part of the story the
question I got is the following
how is it that if we have better
technology today we have all we have the
kind of insight you can get on any of
these social media apps that you've
never had access to the kind of insight
to find out what percentage is 18 to 24
24 to 30 days 35 to this male female
earner income location area country they
can get so deep in Intel that you can
decide I'm better off making this video
in this way because my audience does
better when a video like that you can
really track all of that right why do we
have to do any of this stuff well if we
really use technology today if we
brought the brightest technology folks
on both ends of the aisle okay somebody
from the left somebody on the right so
say say Bezos and musk say to take best
Engineers we have they come in and they
say let's create a technology that's a
hundred percent proven that no way in
the world can be you know cheated for
anything to happen with it why aren't we
doing that we should do that the
European countries do do that even third
world countries have been improving
their election systems so that number
one they know the result immediately
there's no reason to have days and days
and days technology is supposed to make
things faster not slower and uh but the
reason it doesn't happen now and the
reason doesn't happen in America is that
I call it like special logic and here's
what I mean you have things that work in
every other sphere of life but the
moment you raise them in the context of
Elections you're accused of voter
suppression here's a classic example
voter ID right if you go to the bank
it's not banking suppression to say you
want to check cash your check show me
your ID it's not Airline suppression if
you show up at the airport you want to
travel show me your ID it's normal
everybody expects you to do it uh you
want to buy alcohol and on and on it
goes but in the one area of Elections
you show up with an i oh this is going
to be really scary blacks and Hispanics
aren't going to be able to vote because
they don't know where to get an ID is
ridiculous same thing with electronic
surveillance you have electronic
surveillance everywhere but you put it
on a Dropbox suddenly you'll hear oh
you're gonna scare people away they're
gonna knock they're not going to want to
vote because they're under observation
they're under observation everywhere
when they go to the mall so when you
whenever you find an argument that only
applies to this special case Geo
tracking the same nobody questions the
Geo tracking works in the January 6th if
you look at the charging documents Mr X
was 20 feet outside the front door of
the capital Mr y was 20 30 feet inside
the front door the geotracking is
assumed to be reliable yet suddenly when
we use it to track mules going to
dropboxes oh I don't know Dinesh this
technology is very new it doesn't really
work so this is this is a clue that
somebody doesn't want the process to
really to be on the up and up that makes
sense so I I want to read the story that
just came out I'm sure you've seen this
yourself NPR wapo inside it's all over
the place New York Times I'll read uh
let's read the wapo one okay so wapa's
story comes out Washington Post
says uh one of Dinesh de Sosa's two
thousand alleged mule sues claiming
defamation rightly commentated Dinesh De
Sosa welcome to special guest to his
podcast on Tuesday former president
Donald Trump two the two spent about 20
minutes discussing subject that has uh
animated them both for the past two
years false claims about rampant uh uh
ballot uh fraud affecting the outcome of
the 2020 elections Trump has seen the
Soldiers film 2000 mules he held the
screening of the film at his Mar-A-Lago
event facility he's advocated for it
regularly and for good reason two
thousand meals per uh perpetrates to
show that Trump didn't lose his election
re-election bid but rather that it was
stolen by a network of people shuttling
ballots around swing States the film is
entirely uncovering both in its specific
assertions about the number of ballots
shuttled a figure that De Sosa admitted
to wapo was essentially a guess and in
its overall methodology but no one on
his pla on this planet is less is by his
obviously false claims about voter fraud
than Trump after declaring that he won
by millions of votes Trump praised two
thousand meals as being a conclusive way
uh uh uh particularly particularly
useful to his effort to subvert his loss
this film he said uh showed fraud in a
very conclusive way because you were
taking government tapes as evidence that
is the film's claim that a group of uh
called the vote uh true Default true
devote had compiled your location data
to show people visiting multiple
dropboxes was augmented by video from
those dropboxes and who could argue
without with that one person who could
uh who could is Mark Andrews so who's
Mark Andrews who argues with your uh
2000 mules so all right so let's start
with Mark Andrews in 2000 mules we use
this technology to identify these mules
going to multiple locations then as I
said in a few cases and now we're
talking about Fulton County Georgia we
said we do have some video so let's go
look at the videotape we see this Mark
Andrews guy uh and now in the movie
actually to be honest for for legal
reasons and because this is a law
enforcement matter we blur the faces of
all the mules so you see the guy but you
actually can't see his face you can't
see Mark andrews's face but is Mark
Andrews
um apparently and he's putting multiple
ballots into the box
now let's turn for a moment to the uh
election law in Georgia in in Georgia
you are allowed to put in the ballots of
your it's Mark Andrews the one with the
long hair that's sitting there and it's
you can see his face
was his face shown in the documentary no
no his face is not shown in the
documentary
um he his face is blurred uh you can
kind of see his outline okay uh you can
see kind of his ball dish he doesn't
have long hair right and uh and there he
is and he puts uh five ballots in now
very interestingly this is unrelated to
the movie somebody in Georgia made a
complaint about Mark Andrews and Georgia
sent an investigator to Mark andrews's
house and talked to him and he said oh
yeah I was just putting in the ballots
of my family members so George I said oh
okay and they basically dropped the
matter they said this is this is
legitimate and they said that uh they
said that we are concluding that we
don't have any evidence that he was
doing anything improper
um now
um obviously when you're doing research
we have resources of being able to look
at other video other drop boxes Geo
tracking of phones I won't go into the
Mark Andrews case only because he's
filed a suit so I don't actually want to
I don't want to address it just because
it's something that might precede the
trial and you know let's just say that
we have we have a good rebuttal but I'm
gonna withhold that let me make a couple
of General points about all this
all of this started right after election
day when it was announced and I'm not
sure who started this but everyone began
to Echo it the 2020 election was the
most secure election in history you
probably heard it you probably heard it
many times and the first question you
have to ask is a
how would you know that and number two
it's one thing to say we had an election
we haven't seen enough proof of fraud
but to actually make a positive claim
that this was the most secure election
requires you to now produce evidence
showing that there was less fraud in
2020 than in the previous elections
right that's what that statement means
less fraud in 2020 compared to 2016 2012
2008 2004. so ask yourself how do you
measure and what did you do and how did
you measure right to my knowledge not
only has no one ever demonstrated no one
has even attempted to show that 2020 has
the least amount of Fraud and for the
reason I gave earlier which is that
absentee ballots are more vulnerable
than normal types of voting it's very
unlikely that when you change all the
rules of an election very often 15
minutes before the election that you can
declare afterward hey by the way this
was the safest so from the beginning
there was a rather dubious or put it
let's say a dogmatic claim but here's
the interesting thing if you challenge
that claim in any way you are a big liar
you're an election denier they began to
censor you on social media for
questioning an unsupportable and
unsupported claim this is long before I
even made a movie did you dive in Dinesh
to see like the origin of that like who
the media was quoting or where it was
coming from where where you're saying it
all started to pop up what did your
research show the origin of the claim or
the story from like a not a pundit not a
reporter but like a government Source I
want you to do that but go back to a
point you want to make as well so
address that and then go back to the
point you were going to make yeah the
guy I saw on uh the government official
who said that and he's in the movie is a
guy named Krebs Chris Krebs Krabs and
he's the head of a group or was the head
of a group called sisa the cyber
security and infrastructure agency so
this is the guy supposedly doing the
electronic oversight of the election but
of course the type of fraud we described
in 2000 mules is not it's it's a high
high-tech way of busting it but it's
low-tech fraud it's actual mules dumping
in ballots we're not talking about
machines rigging votes you know we're
not talking about any of that we're
talking about old school fraud you know
go back to the 19th century immigrants
come off the boat some political
officials meet them they go Hey listen
we'll give you a bottle of whiskey go
talk to my friend you know Gustavo he'll
give you a job and by the way here's a
ballot you sign over here we'll fill it
out for you this has been going on in
America for a long time we're talking
about this kind of old school type of
fraud turn to Trump for a second uh
Trump did not host
um 2000 mules we wanted to have our our
Premiere I've done my premieres via the
Chinese Theater in LA that's my usual
spot for having them this time we
decided since we're on the East Coast
it'd be kind of fun to have it in
Mar-A-Lago so we showed the film to
Trump because it's his house and I also
was really clear though this is a 90
minute film if you watch the film while
you watched it Patrick
Trump is not in the film for more than
three minutes because I didn't want to
make it all about Trump I didn't want to
have interview Trump and Trump so
because this is really about the
Integrity of the vote and it's about
democracy so we have the usual Trump ran
in 2020 so we have Trevi show Trump on
Election Day and so on but this is not a
movie about Trump so the reason the
Washington Post is trying to make it
seem like it's a movie about Trump is
they want to make it sound like oh Trump
gave Dinesh a pardon and that's just
trying to pay back Trump the we don't
have to even look at this movie because
this is like a no it's not but for the
average person that could be a valid
like uh Theory you can say okay I can
see that happening he's returning the
favor if I do this will you do this for
me the average person will say I can see
that happening right and my answer to
the average guy is okay listen look the
beauty of this movie uh is the evidence
of the movie is in the movie so you
don't have to worry about what dinesh's
motives are you just go in with an open
mind and your own two eyes now you know
there's as you know there's a psych
called Rotten Tomatoes and over 500
people have reviewed the movie in Rotten
Tomatoes what's the movie's rating
unheard of for this kind of movie 100
why because even liberals even Democrats
who see the movie go whoa what the
heck's going on over here you know in
other words we don't just allege a heist
we can actually show you the heist yeah
there it is 100 we can show you the
heist and so you only have to believe
your own two eyes so I guess the
question with that is if I'm just
throwing this out there if a hundred
percent of the audience is already a
trump fan you know mag a country of
course they're gonna agree with it so I
guess my question is do you have
analytics that show who has actually
watched your film like for instance if
it was you said 20 million people that
watch your film
if it was 50 50 and it's a hundred all
right whoa we're on to something but if
it's all Republicans all Maga all Trump
fans of course they're gonna agree so
how do you respond to that do you know
the analytics actually I do for this
reason I went to the Rasmussen posters
and asked them to do something I done
with my Obama film I told them can you
bring a bunch of people in a room who
are politically independent now the way
they decide you're gonna find those
people I know no no this is how they do
it there's actually a metric for doing
it like for example when in my Obama
film they picked people who had voted
for Obama in 2008 but Republicans in
2010 okay okay so they picked people who
have gone on boats or even in 2016
you're saying they voted Obama and then
they voted Trump yeah those types of
people those types of people and so what
they do those tastes would have been
Obama and then Hillary uh I'm sorry
Obama and then Trump because see
obviously Obama didn't run in 16 it was
Hillary
um in any event Rasmussen said we won't
do that but what we will do is will do a
national survey on 2000 mules and they
did they did a representative sample
they did a national survey on this movie
and what they found is that sure enough
not surprisingly about 72 percent of
people who saw the movie right Wingers
they're Republicans so but the other 28
broke down into about half of
Independence and half of Democrats maybe
they were just curious maybe they didn't
know what the movie was about but what's
interesting is that even among those
groups Independents and Democrats not
everybody but big majorities were
persuaded that now they might debate the
movie was there enough fraud that Trump
would have won the election that's a
separate issue but that there was
systematic fraud I think pretty much
anyone who sees the movie is that a
hundred percent meaning that they liked
the movie or agreed with the points of
the movie because that's a big
difference like you could watch and be
like that was an awesome movie I mean I
don't really believe it but it was great
so you'll give it like a thumbs up but
you might not believe the story within
the story but not listen not for this
kind of movie this is the kind in a
movie where I don't want to get stuck on
Rotten Tomatoes I want to move on to
issues can you do me a favor go to
Rotten Tomatoes and type in his prior
movie that he did for Obama or any one
of them so just type in what was another
one Hillary's America that's right do
Hillary is a good example yeah and and
that'll kind of give you an idea go
right there it's right around the bottom
click on that so let's see what the
score is and I don't know what the score
is to be on okay there you go eighty
percent four percent so that means
Rotten Tomato on the left so Adam if you
zoom in a little bit more the guys on
the left are tomato meters meaning those
are the people that work for Rotten
Tomatoes yeah they gave it four percent
make sense 28 reviews they hated it it
sucked right professional experience and
then on the right 80 percent 10 000 plus
ratings that's still solid for something
like this we were just kind of talking
about this I know we don't want to get
stuck on Rotten Tomatoes I get it but we
did discuss this exact same topic the
other day with Doug Ellen about
Entourage right about how basically the
score on the right isn't necessarily
reflectable to score the left because
the critics don't know [ __ ] let's let's
go with the audience knows all right all
I'm saying is 100 to me it doesn't do
anything for me to give it more
credibility or less credibility to me as
because I don't uh first of all what I
was impressed is the fact that Rotten
Tomatoes The Tomato meters didn't even
want to review right two thousand meals
to give it any credibility as if it's
not a real documentary like to them it's
an insult to say Dinesh is a nobody so
we'll only give it two reviews and the
prior one got 28 reviews they don't want
to bring that kind of eyeballs to give
it attention but the reality but there's
a lot of people have watched this
documented I'm wondering what the hell
is going on so they want to know a
little bit more what's going on so let's
let's continue with this let's continue
with this on the point we're trying to
make so Mark Andrews what happened with
uh you were making a point with Mark
Andrews on the fact that they're coming
back and they're suing you know you for
the doc what point were you gonna make
with him well Mark and Mark Andrews are
simply saying I'm not a quote mule he's
not even disputing necessarily that the
movie is inaccurate he's simply saying
he was wrongly identified as a mule out
of 2000 only one is suing you only one
but so so so okay did you did you hear
that Tom loud and clear out of 2 000
only one is suing you
that that is that's not good for the
other side yeah why isn't there someone
like a Gloria alred who's really good at
rounding up women on hashtag me too and
putting five of them in front of the
camera why isn't there a a a a leftist
lawyer like that rounding up people to
do it I that's what I'm thinking like a
class action lawsuit or something yeah
just real quick we show a lot that's
kind of shock to clarify did you name
two thousand mules did you just name
Mark Andrews like how how did Mark
Andrews find out that he was in the
documentary did you name him
specifically do you name other people no
we don't name any mules
um remember one thing to tell you about
Geo tracking when you sell when you Geo
track people's phones you don't get
their names you get the ID of their
phones okay so for example all our
phones have a unique ID it's not the
phone number but it's in our phone and
so if you run a Geo tracking search
let's just say for example and by the
way this is how good this technology is
if somebody is murdered in Piedmont Park
in Atlanta in the middle of the night no
eyewitnesses all you you have is a body
first thing the cops do they run a
geofence around that Park and they look
for all the cell phone devices in that
Park and what they get is the cell phone
ID now they have to go to a judge and
the judge will give you a warrant and
then you go to the cell phone provider
and they give you the names phone
numbers and addresses of all those
people then you can go talk to them now
one of the ways you know that somebody
is making an honest documentary is you
say all right I'm gonna we have all
these two thousand meals and their cell
phone IDs we're willing to give this to
any law enforcement that wants it right
all you have to do is go interview the
mules and ask them who paid you who gave
you those ballots who organized this
operation so I'm calling for this I'm
willing to put my thesis on the line and
if I'm wrong go interview the mules and
they'll have an innocent explanation
they'll be like oh man we're all like
Mark Andrews we're all just dropping off
the ballots of our family members it's
all on the up and up Dinesh has nothing
here but they don't want to do that so
and the left doesn't want them to do
that fill a bump of the Washington Post
who's written like 20 articles on
Twitter thousand meals he's like he's
scared of law enforcement going go go go
to the left-wing non-profits and ask
them Hey listen you got all this money
to get out the vote can we see your
records to see if you've been organizing
these mules are you providing ballots
where are you getting them no there in
other words when someone is trying to
block the investigation from moving
forward I would say that's on the that's
probably my face she's suspicious so so
so here's here's why I'm asking a
question so check this out DeSean Watson
first person comes out right remember
it's like well you know I was giving him
a massage and then you remember you and
I were talking about it because Sean
he's a guy I wanted to buy his best card
so I'm like hey what's the story all
about and then he's like well you may
want to hold off because the second
person came in and the third person came
out and a fourth and a fifth eventually
was what 28. well guess what at about 20
something do you believe that that
actually happened with DeSean right
after all those allegations yeah so
there's five yeah I mean so Ellen
DeGeneres she's a very tough person to
work with as a boss she's a one person
two people ten people twenty probably
she's got high expectations and it's
tough to work with right you know
coaches you would hear stories to only
have one of two thousand come out it's a
little weird let me give you the other
part the other part so you know the
whole 81 million votes let's play that
you know to say your argument is wrong
two thousand meals you're just kind of
doing a favor for Trump come on Dinesh
let's face it I mean obviously a great
opportunity you made a lot of money if
20 million people watch it they pay 20
bucks you make good money good for you
this is a big victory for you if we're
going to dinner tonight you're paying
for it we're getting a nice bottle of
wine but aside from that if Democrats
are sitting there saying guys do us a
favor
help Biden win
allow us to have the Senate allow us to
have the house we're going to show you
that Russia was behind this with Trump
okay so then Democrats are like what
hell yeah
if this guy really did do something with
Russia guess what let's take him down
I'm going to vote Democrat and then you
vote Democrat six months goes by 12
months goes by 24 months goes by
nothing's going on there here's the
scary part
if and they've all been saying the same
thing if Republicans win the house and
the Senate their biggest fear is some of
these investigations may actually start
and that's why some of these guys on the
other side like you heard what Hillary
said if you want to post what Hillary
just recently said a story that you know
you can't talk here's Hillary Hillary
Clinton GOP has planned to literally
steal 2024 election it's kind of weird
that she gets away with saying this kind
of stuff and she said this on what she
said this on an interview what was the
context of this this was like a week ago
right yeah a couple weeks ago yeah
Hillary GOP has literally planned plan
to literally steal 2024 election she's
been saying this Pelosi said it back in
the days even the speaker uh what do you
call it the person that represents yeah
she said that and that came up and uh
but but if but if what you're saying is
true if you have enough you know to show
data do you think if the right wins uh
Senate and the house they're going to go
investigate 2020 elections or no well I
I hope that they do I know there are
some congressmen and Senators who will
push for it but I will also say that
I've detected this has been maybe my
greatest frustration with this film has
been that there is a sort of a GOP
establishment right and their view is uh
let's move on Dinesh why are you making
this film let's not look in the rear
view mirror we need to move on and part
of it is that these guys are not
entirely unhappy that Trump lost in
2020. in other words their view is that
Hey listen if Trump and the Republicans
both got clobbered that'd be really bad
but Trump lost but the Republicans down
ballot did pretty well so here is their
scheme that is Biden's gonna come and
he's going to be horrible there's going
to be a public Revolt throw the
Democrats out and the Republicans come
back in but without Trump so there's a
sort of a republican feeling that 2020
the 2000 mules is kind of spoiling the
Republican picnic right now like Dinesh
is not cooperating with the team so I
want them to have these hearings I think
we should get to the bottom of it and
again you know this is all a case where
if there's nothing to it show us same
with Russia collusion yeah what you're
saying Mitch McConnell is all all but
said everything you just said
yeah the problem with Mitch McConnell is
he's a tricky character I mean he he is
pulling money out from Don bolduck who
is running even with Maggie Hassan in
New Hampshire think of it Republicans
could take a blue State uh and and the
polls are 50 50. and he's putting the
money to support Lisa murkowski in
Alaska against a Republican Kelly
Shabaka so why is he doing that because
basically it's about it's not even about
whether you're a republican it's are you
on Mitch's team Lisa murkowski is on
Mitch's team Kelly Shabaka is like a
trumpster she's a Maga type he's fine he
has his own complicated agenda I'm not
not entirely against Mitch but I'm
saying Mitch is known to play these
kinds of inside baseball type of games
what's the well you move down the I'm
sorry go ahead what's the relationship
with Mitch and Trump at this point we
know that it's all strained even like
establishment Republicans whether it's a
a Romney or a a pence or a mitch you
know these establishment Republicans
where they with Trump these days Mitch
specifically though I know I think I
think the relations are there's a cold
war between Mitch and Trump and partly
it's the Trump calls Mitch like you've
broken all Crow and names like that and
I don't think you should do that to be
honest but he doesn't do that he ain't
the only one Dinesh let's get a nickname
from Trump yeah so he does that stuff
and then Mitch you know Mitch is an old
establishment guy and I don't think he
likes it and he's uh so there there's a
very uneasy relationship there who do
you think has more power within
government within like the actual
senators and representatives a McConnell
or McConnell McConnell McConnell has
more power on the legislative process
but to be honest Trump has far more
power with the base with the people yeah
with the people of course so if Trump
does get reelected right I mean we're
fast forwarding how's that relationship
going to work because it's so beyond
strained at this point assuming
McConnell's still there in the Senate at
some level I mean look they're similar
he might be the Senate Majority Leader
if they take it over in 2022 next week
yeah there's there are
um there are similar strains on the
Democratic side they're not as obvious
the media doesn't cover them the truth
of it is both parties can function with
some levels of strains because they're
United by you know philosophy uh less
government and
um more personal Liberty and you know
and they're United also by their
hostility to the other party and the bad
stuff that comes out of the other side
so to me it's not impossible that Trump
and McConnell could work together
although I think that there is likely to
be at some point a movement to challenge
McConnell in part because McConnell is
also getting really old right but there
it's way more strained on the right
meaning like the mid McConnell and Trump
situation is way worse than like a
Schumer Pelosi Biden situation I don't
even think it's terrible right yeah
that's right that is right yeah I
brought up McConnell simply because
that's the narrative that that
that sliver of the Republican party that
is over Trump by their own words not by
my accusation by their own words is
there but where in the Republican Party
are those people that would like to see
an investigation simply to do what
you're saying hey let's go count it
let's let law enforcement dive in let's
go look at the data and let's all sit
back and get away from the microphone
and and posturing and hypothesizing and
let's look at data who in the Republican
Party
is is with you to say hey let's go look
at this and if the date is credible
let's show it so that would be by and
large the people in the so-called Mago
make America great again wing of the
Republican Party classic example would
be right now I think it's possible that
all the four major candidates in Arizona
will win uh it could be three maybe
Blake Masters will lose to Mark Kelly
but I think Kerry Lake will win
um her race of mock comedy will win for
attorney general Mark fincham for
secretary of state so all those guys are
major Advocates of 2000 meals they came
to our screening they've talked up the
movie so those this is the kind of new
face of the Republican party that will
be like we need to have an investigation
we need to have hearings now admittedly
Carrie licks running for governor she's
not running for Senator for congress but
that's the sensibility we're talking
about so it's the Lauren bobert's and
stuff that are on the Congressional side
yes but it's also it's not just that
it's also people who are more to the
mainstream I mean I've had Steve scalise
in my podcast guys he's concerned Tom
Cotton people like that who have power
in the Republican party but are not
necessarily right now in leadership
within the Republican Party do you kind
of have to pick a side I'm a Maga guy or
I'm just a traditional Republican like
how does that break down and where do
you fall in line there so what's
happening in the Republican party is you
know think of how strange it is you know
when I came to America in 1978 the the
left and the right were quite different
than they are today if you met a leftist
on a campus I was a Dartmouth I met a
lot of leftists for the first time here
were their big issues you know number
one they were Defenders of minorities in
the working class number two they care
about individual civil liberties
um and this applied from everything to
free speech to abortion like get the
government off my back let my
individuality flourish and number three
they were against the Cold War they were
against War they were the peace party
so just take those three things right
now and they flipped on their head in 78
right 78 to six years after Vietnam yeah
six years after Vietnam it's fresh it's
fresh and now the you talk to the left
about the working class they're like oh
yeah look there's a bunch of morons so
those guys are a bunch of truck drivers
and bombs you know make them wear their
masks you know so there's a hostility to
the working class no surprise the
working class is pushing toward the
Republican Party number two civil
liberties I mean the biggest issue of
civil liberties is an abortion it's can
you speak your mind I mean can you just
talk uh and on all these key platforms
the left has become the party of
censorship not just the leadership the
ordinary Democrat wants to shut you down
and shut your speech off and allow
speech to be regulated by the big Tech
platforms if possible but if they won't
do it by the government and there's all
kinds of survey data to support that and
number three suddenly the left has
become their pro-fbi the pro CIA and the
pro war I mean they're even saying
things like you know we we if Biden
talks about World War III they're on
board
so think of the change that's occurred
there there's a similar change occurring
on the Republican side a party that's
becoming you know somewhat more working
class I mean when I was in when I was in
college if you met a guy who's a CEO of
a company that was an 80 chance that
guy's a republican now does an 80 chance
that guy's a Democrat so so no wonder
the the old Republican guard is used to
relying on the business guy the you know
the oil guy the Chamber of Commerce guy
that's their team and suddenly those
guys are being challenged and all these
new people are coming in so that's what
that is what's going on in the ground
and and Maga and the establishment are
just metaphors for this really big
sweeping change occurring at the ground
level
fair enough
do you have a follow-up no where so
where do you fall in on the Maga
Republican side of things well today I
think if you ask most people they'd be
like well Dinesh is in the mega wing and
I guess I am but I came out of the other
Wing in other words if you look at my
background I mean I'm not some guy who
like you know is a plumber right decide
to run for office I mean I came up with
a mainstream of the Republican Party my
mentor was a was a guy who was the
deputy to Bill Buckley at the National
Review my early articles were at
National Review I then went to work for
policy review which is a policy magazine
I went to the Reagan White House I
worked there for two years then I joined
the American Enterprise Institute the
think tank I was there for 10 years then
the Hoover institution in Stanford so
this couldn't be a more mainstream path
of the Republican establishment the only
difference is that after that and I
think actually my my case with the Obama
Administration you know I was at an
election
um you know I exceeded the campaign
Finance law as I was you know in a
confinement Center for eight months all
that experience
helped to sort of help me see a part of
America I hadn't seen before I think
that helped to shift my politics a
little bit is it also one last follow-up
is it also that if you are a republican
it's like you're a dead man walking if
you're on the Liz Cheney Camp the ASM
Adam kinzinger Kent the uh what's it do
to where's the eye patch to Dan Crenshaw
Dan crunch like if you're in that camp
like you're a dead man walking so it's
like either get on board with the Maga
train or you're gonna get run over so is
it like I'm not even saying about you
but do people just kind of have to be
opportunistic and they're like yeah I
kind of have these principles but if I
want to win elections or get money or
donations or or even you know fulfill
what my base wants to hear I gotta get
on board with the Maga Camp well I think
actually that's
um I I'd like to Nuance that a little
bit because there's a huge difference
between let's say Liz Cheney on the one
side and then let's take Brian Kemp and
Dan Crenshaw so Dan can Crenshaw is my
congressman
um and Dan Crenshaw won by 75 of the
vote he won the Primary easily uh what
state is in is this is in Texas this is
in Texas the governor of uh Georgia yeah
and he's running in Stacey Abrams but
he's leading by over 10 points yeah
again right so what I'm getting on here
and he entered into a big Skirmish with
Trump huge Skirmish I mean the whole
Raphael Warnock and the situation of the
Senate was a disaster they lost two
Senate seats because of that Skirmish
that's right and I think honestly there
was a lot of blame to go around by which
I mean I think that the the charges of
election fraud were made in an
irresponsible way and many people
thought well if the whole process is
rigged why should I go vote and so in a
red State you have voters who don't vote
horrible that's what helped that outcome
to happen and then there was a Blame
Game to follow that who's responsible
for losing those Senate seats is it the
Brian Kemp establishment or is it Trump
and that that continued after a while so
here's what I'm getting at Liz Cheney
has basically become at least in the
view of most Republicans and operative
for the Democratic party she mainly
attacks Republicans she endorses
Democrats so she's in a whole different
she's basically become the face of the
January 6th commission and again look I
mean there are guys on January 6 who
should have not done what they did they
should not have broken those glass they
should not have they should not have
engaged in any skirmishes with the cops
but then there's a whole bunch of other
people who walk in there nobody stops
them the cops standing around they walk
in they're there for 10 minutes and now
they're in solitary confinement I mean
there's no excuse for that that that if
they were on the left that would never
have happened to them that's the key
point and that's really that's really
all we're saying about January 6th is
that there needs to be some Equity of
treatment so he announced yesterday that
you know not he announced but your story
got out that he's going to announce
November 14 that he's gonna run I'm sure
you saw the story was all over the place
Trump yeah Trump that he's uh do you
think any of this January 6th or any of
the raid FBI Mar-A-Lago any of that's
going to prevent him from making a run
for 2024.
no although I think that is the left's
intention they want to keep him off the
ticket you can really see with all these
cases they are they are uh they've
already got the criminal and now they're
looking for the crime which is not the
way it should be you you should have a
reason to go look at somebody but
they're on a fishing Expedition let's
get him on something and that's
troubling it's troubling uh it's
troubling because it's Trump but it's
also troubling because it's starting to
happen to other people so so it's
starting to happen to people who are you
know at pro-life rallies now they're
actually trying to go after people who
watch dropboxes this is the latest thing
now when a Dropbox doesn't have 24-hour
surveillance and people watch our movie
they're like well you know what I'll go
have a tailgate party we'll have some
beers we'll sit outside the Dropbox and
we'll just see if any Shenanigans Go On
by the way this is perfectly legal the
dropboxes are on public property you're
a citizen you're sitting there you know
I don't know if he maybe can't have a
beer that's having a diet coke uh
nothing to prevent you from watching a
Dropbox now you shouldn't show up in
your military fatigues don't be cleaning
your shot exactly
you know they're cleaning your shotgun
from a Dropbox that's going to be pretty
intimidating you're right agreed I mean
we agree on that for sure right um but
some people are doing that well seeing
evidence of that I have seen whether
that's mainstream media making that up I
don't know I've seen one image on social
media of two guys and they're like in
military fatigues and I was like this is
crazy I so we agree yeah um but what
they're doing in the Biden doj has filed
documents they're basically saying that
for people merely to appear drop boxes
and and turn on their cell phones which
again is totally legal totally yeah is
somehow voter suppression and and that's
the point is you know you had asked
earlier Patrick about why can't we have
sort of reasonable discussion about this
where we agree yeah don't do that and in
fact a judge stepped in in Arizona and
basically said that he goes listen
there's nothing to stop citizens from
showing up at a Dropbox that's not
illegal he said just keep a safe
distance away and don't interfere with
voters don't engage with voters if
someone's coming with ballot let them do
what they're doing and I think that is
that was a good way to resolve that
particular
issue well it's also you're saying voter
suppression but I think the term the
correct term in that instance is voter
intimidation right okay so if you see a
person with a shotgun or I mean military
fatigues most people are just going to
show up drop their thing but if you are
maybe the the good thing is if you are
trying to do something illegal and you
see Rick over there with a shotgun
you're gonna be like maybe yeah don't go
over there well you know this happened
by the way I forget if it wasn't in 2008
or 12 but in Philadelphia and you there
are pictures on social media you can
easily pull up there was a bunch of
black panthers with like night sticks
and they were patrolling these uh boxes
these voting ballot boxes and the issue
went up to the Obama doj and they had an
investigation and they concluded nah
this was actually no problem they didn't
file any complaints or any indictments
so but that was a troubling episode that
yeah so you're saying it happens on both
sides well but I think that's BS with
the Black Panthers surrounding a Ballot
Box on the left and the right I think
voter intimidation is not I think we
should have voter encouragement as long
as it's legal of course exactly I mean
this is the meeting point of all of
reasonable discussion how do we maximize
the ability of people to vote and
minimize the ability of people to cheat
that's not a controversial statement so
so going back to it so uh with uh Trump
running so you don't think they're gonna
to be able to stop them they're going to
try to figure out many creative ways
with knowing Trump and you've spent a
lot of time with them you're your
feeling is that he's most likely if he
runs uh he doesn't feel neither one of
those stores are going to get in the way
right I think for Trump it's really a
double whammy number one this is a guy
who hates to lose this is also a guy who
who's willing to lose but if he feels
that he was cheated you know he is
looking for Vindication I mean for him
it's it's just as much about vindicating
the Trump name and his sort of his that
so so this is why I think nothing will
stop him he's going to want the only way
to stop him is sort of somehow to
physically prevent him from being able
to do it
um locking him up something like that
which the left I think is willing to do
they're they're they are terrified about
this guy there's a little bit of hope
that maybe like maybe the Sanders will
challenge Trump maybe you know uh and
there are a few Republicans who take the
view that DeSantis is basically Trump
but with less hassles you it doesn't
have the some of the weaknesses of trump
or he won't bring some of the baggage of
trump and I think that may be true but
here's the other side of it and that is
that it's it's a um it's it's what I
call Adam magnetism you know one time F
Scott Fitzgerald the writer was asked
you know do you think you have a
privileged life and he said well he goes
I don't have the best two things in life
but I've got the second best two things
he goes I've got looks and I've got
intelligence but he goes the best two
things in life to have our money and
animal magnetism and by animal magnetism
he was actually thinking about Ernest
Hemingway where Ernest Hemingway could
go to Spain he's in the bull fight
suddenly you know he's on the you know
he's there with the bull I mean the
Spanish are like cheering Hemingway he
had that kind of so Trump has that if
you have a big room the Santa walks in
let's just say he just walks in as an
ordinary guy not a single head will move
Trump walks in all heads turn Reagan had
the same so that animal magnetism that
Trump has is very difficult if you don't
have it there's no easy way to get a wow
factor it's the wow factor so so if if
these two both run most likely you're
thinking they're both gonna run Trump
and the scientist no I think actually
descent is very cleverly is positioning
himself to either run with Trump or to
run the next time around with yeah with
Trump or the next time around so in
other words Trump DeSantis that would be
the ticket
yeah you think that's a likely scenario
because a lot of people say that the you
know they're both number ones and you
know you can only have one CEO of a
company there's no co-ceo yeah but
that's only true at one time in other
words you can have one CEO but Trump can
only run for four years and DeSantis has
his whole life ahead of him so for
DeSantis it's ultimately about when is
the best time to make that Lifetime move
is it do you want to run against Trump
where first of all the you know the base
of the Republican party is very trumpian
it's going to be kind of hard to beat
Trump now with that base
um on the other hand if DeSantis went in
and came in as a vice president he would
be the automatic presumptive
front-runner Trump would be off the
stage so if I were DeSantis that's what
I would do sure but that that's you know
like even with Biden and Kamala he chose
Kamala you know after the primary or
after the the Republican RNC meaning
that was DNC apologize that was after
the debates okay so are you saying that
um this Santas won't even go on the
debate stage I'm just kind of waiting
the wings for Trump to win and then just
be like all right I'll be your your
lucky little VP because I see him
getting on that stage don't you no I I
think I think they'll I if I again if
I'm the way I'm thinking and I've been
following politics not very closely for
a long time there there are different
ways to pick a VP when Reagan ran in
1980 Reagan picked Bush Reagan didn't
even know Bush so why did he pick bush
bush was the second highest vote getter
in the Republican party it was The
Logical Choice it didn't matter to
Reagan I don't know him
um he goes I'm gonna pick my number too
he's he's gonna be the guy most likely
to carry me over the top so now ask
yourself who's the guy most likely to
help carry Trump over the top and
convince even doubting Republicans that
here's a competent elected official that
kind of knows how to cross the t's and
Dot the eyes that will help Trump with
some of what may be seen as Trump's
weaknesses and the obvious guy is the
Santa's he knows how to run a state
what's so funny Pat oh my my God if if
that I I
yeah I don't know I don't know but if
that were to happen
let me tell you I mean it's it's a
nightmare for the left for 12 years if
that were to happen for 12 years
the the left will need to see their
therapist two or three times a week
instead of the one a week yeah it's it's
because they're both Vindication type of
guys both of them are yeah the santis is
so is Trump you don't want those two to
be your opponent for 12 years uh they're
they're not the type of people that are
going in just to you know there's
different types of people in life
there are those that are resume chasing
resume Chasers want to be able to say I
worked at Google I worked at Amazon I
worked under XYZ I worked under this
person there's resume Chasers that go
get their PHD or Masters or MBA just to
say I got a masters I gotta this there's
resume Chasers that want to go to Oxford
or Yale or Harvard to say I went I want
to work the resume Chasers right their
resume Chasers that eventually just want
to be CPAs or CFOs or CEOs one time just
to say I was
and then you got guys that are Crusaders
and True Believers that are not chasing
a title or resume and that's the
sentence and Trump neither one of those
guys are chasing that Biden for the rest
of his life will be a president that's
just going to be in the history books
he's a resume Chaser he for the rest of
his life's gonna be that there's people
like that on the left there's people
like that on the right there's people
like that in sports there's people like
that in politics there's people like
that in churches there's people like
that everywhere not these two families
these two guys are very weird very
different you do not want there's
certain people in life you don't want as
enemies those two you don't want as
enemies if that were to happen which I
don't know if that would happen because
in a perfect world like are you selling
this or are you saying this based on
Insight or are you saying this based on
I think this will happen what's your
position when you're saying this yeah
I'm not advocating it I think it will
happen okay guys and the reason I'm
saying it is not again this is not my
field I'm not a pollster I'm not a but
what what it is it's just based upon the
observation there are certain natural
laws in politics as in foreign policy
right for example years ago when I was
in in college a professor of mine said
look let's look at the map of the world
okay and let's forget about communism
and capitalism and left wing and right
wing and let's just look at the the
world is divided into big blobs and
small blobs they're big countries
they're big blobs big circles then
they're small countries around them
those are small blobs now based upon
just looking at the world like that and
knowing nothing about it you're from
Mars can you predict how this world will
shake out which which countries would be
allied with which countries which
countries will be fighting with which
countries and the truth of it is you can
have a whole seminar where you see that
the big countries are all rivals and the
small countries now Ally with the big
countries near them to become in order
to get protection but other small
countries that were likely to be gobbled
up will try to find big countries
elsewhere that can support them and then
you look at the world and it's happening
like that you know so similarly when you
look at American politics and you say to
yourself everyone's thinking in terms of
their own self-interest and if you if
you look at DeSantis and you say I just
okay I'm this antis I'm the number two
guy do I actually want to run against
the number one guy right now and run the
risk where If I Lose I'm bruised enough
that other people now start coming to
the front and the sort of Maga mentality
will now so that the next time around it
may be Kerry Lake I don't want that I
want to make sure that I am the only guy
that is on the inside track and nobody
will even dare to challenge me the way I
do that is I essentially go into Trump's
tent recognizing that for Trump there's
only one more time to go around the
block yeah I I know okay so let me give
you my uh uh uh the devil's advocate of
that just let's have a nice friendly
debate here on this one here okay so and
I'm not disagreeing with you on what
you're saying fully agree I come from
Iran I live there so I understand what
it is for certain countries have to hey
let me I'm not going to team up with the
U.S may as well team up with China
Israel U.S you know Armenia Russia you
know Azerbaijan turkey I get I get what
you're saying but here's the part so
would you who would you say is more
pro-trump
um DeSantis or lake
Lake okay is it even a question no she
said the other day my second my husband
is my my second favorite person
she says because my favorite person is
Trump okay so it's fair to say she's
more pro-trump right than the scientist
right is it fair to say that Lake Trump
and DeSantis all have similar backbones
yes okay they're all tough they're not
lightweights you can't push them around
She's Not Afraid the Santa is not afraid
and obviously Trump Is Not Afraid okay
a a if if you had to choose between
those two as a VP for Trump which one
would you choose
I would choose DeSantis but I can also
see that there is a there could be a
personality weakness that will cause
Trump to pick Lake in other words it's a
personality weakness if somebody is all
about the flattery it's a personality
weakness if someone says I need to pick
the person who thinks I'm the greatest
and if that is Trump's Soul metric and
there are some people who think it is he
will pick like for that reason but what
I'm saying is that if Trump is thinking
in terms of his own best interest and
his own best interest alone then he will
say that look there were things that I
didn't do the last time I've got to be
honest about my own presidency I should
have fired Comey on day one I would have
avoided myself a whole lot of problems
had I done that I should have gotten rid
of Christopher Ray I need an inside
administrative guy who is a massive ass
kicker and and I need someone who has
the experience of doing that and would
have the trust of the Republican base
that they will do that for me who's that
guy
that's going to be DeSantis Carrie lake
is a newcomer she's a newscaster she's
going to be a first term let's just say
she wins she'll be a first term Governor
let her get her experience there's
probably gonna be I mean hey you talk
about 12 years they could be a DeSantis
scary Lake ticket 12 years from now so
in other words these people have not in
12 years four years from now six years
from now yeah so I'm just saying there
are options down the road but I would if
I were Trump I would not go with
somebody as new as Carrie like now let
me give you the DeSantis argument for
the people that are pro de santis I I
fully understand the uh uh pro-trump
argument I understand the like argument
let's talk about the descentesis
argument
the people who are in his ear okay
there's a difference between who gives
me advice versus what I know what's
going on meaning people can tell me pal
let me tell you here's who you are
you're so this you're so down like we're
not there yet we're three years away but
I appreciate the compliment but we're
not there yet right
who do you what do you think people
around DeSantis are telling them you
think they're telling them I think if
Trump calls you as a VP you take it I
think you start negotiating right now
with Trump for you to be the VP or do
you think people on this Camp are saying
everybody in America is modeling after
your state the chances of having this
opportunity again may not happen for a
long time because we're going to forget
about covet in six years because 2024
you got 2028 ain't nobody talking covet
in 2028 they're going to be like dude
covet was 10 years ago because in 27
2028 it's going to be what seven eight
years ago right people are over it
they've moved on by that time so if he
runs on his record of covet in 2027 2028
nothing's going to happen there right
and then if he you know and then you
know if he sits and waits and then he
runs on the uh you know the uh his
record as a governor under Trump they're
going to say well because Trump was a
president it wasn't really you it's
because Trump trump was really the
president this is your time to run you
out a run so as much as you know many
Republicans I'm sure think a trump
DeSantis ticket is game over yes I also
don't know the council that's being
given to the centers behind closed doors
is hey you you should be open to the
number two idea rather than the number
one idea I don't know if I see that
good point I don't know what the
DeSantis team is telling him uh I do
know DeSantis
um and um DeSantis interestingly when um
when DeSantis was in Congress
DeSantis was a guy who helped me during
my case with the with the um with the
Obama people because in Congress you can
get access to information remember the
Republicans control the Congress and so
they got a hold the Congressional
committee got a hold of my FBI file and
they say hey Dinesh DeSantis tells me he
says inside your FBI file even before
your case began they flag you as like a
right winger and what he's getting at is
that look if you're pursuing a campaign
Finance case you're not supposed to be
looking at the politics of the guy
because it's almost like the FBI was
telling the the Obama doj this is one
guy you may want to go after because
he's one of our political opponents
that's really what DeSantis was all
about so I think you're right I think
for DeSantis the question is this if he
if he wants to make this a kind of a
covid run
then he has a window of opportunity but
I think what DeSantis is doing and what
he's showing people and the reason
people really like him is that while
most Republicans come in and they sit on
their hands for two years or four years
and they do nothing they just make some
symbolic statements the sentence is like
if it's Monday we need an election Fraud
Unit and if it's Tuesday we need to go
after affirmative action and then on
Wednesday we're going to start up on
this and so this guy like never stops
that's right right that's what people
are looking for by the way both of them
are like that they're both like that
yeah both so that's what will Propel the
Santa so if DeSantis is going to run he
shouldn't think of himself as a covet
candidate but he should think of himself
as let me identify the real nonsense
going on in this country and become the
guy that's not afraid to take all that
on in rhetoric and then in policy let me
ask the other question can you ever see
Reagan uh or Trump being a VP
believe it or not I can see it more with
Reagan than with Trump with Trump it's
harder to see because of Just The Way
Trump is I mean Trump is the other thing
is when you see Trump he's a little
different you know I've had a chance I
didn't know Trump by the way when people
say oh give you a pardon me and so on
when Trump gave me a pardon I'd never
met the guy
um so so it wasn't like he was doing me
a favor or he owed me or anything like
that but since then I've gotten to know
him a little better and he's he's a very
interesting fellow but he also is like
he marches to his own drummer and and
Reagan did not do that Reagan in in the
end was in fact a party man uh in fact
Reagan has famous statements where he
says things like never criticize your
own party you know that's the 11th
commandment of being a republican so
with Reagan let's just say in a freak
case had had Gerald Ford offered him the
vice president I think Reagan would have
taken it quick question he pardoned you
how do number one what were you pardoned
for how does that process work you were
legally you were in trouble you weren't
in jail were you were nothing like that
how does that work and how does that
phone call happen and then like do you
get to send them a thank you note like
legitimately how does this work well
what happened was my case involved my
case was a college friend of mine
um that I'd known for 20 years decided
to run for the senate in New York her
name is Wendy long and so I told her not
to do it I'm like you're not seasoned in
politics because I'm gonna run so she
ran and and I said okay I'll give you I
was you're allowed to give ten thousand
dollars in a campaign so I wrote a check
for ten thousand dollars and then my
Obama movie came out uh this is 2012 and
I'm traveling around the country
promoting it I'm doing all these shows
and stuff and Wendy's like you know when
you serve on my finance committee hey
Dinesh you know I know these Indian
doctors you're Indian can you come to a
dinner or may help them give my account
give to my campaign so I felt really bad
so I called up two of my friends and I
said hey guys you like Wendy long give
her 10 grand that's the campaign limit
and I'll reimburse you little did I know
this was a really stupid thing to do
because this Falls a foul of the
campaign Finance law but it is almost
never prosecuted or if it's ever
discovered they send you a letter they
give you a warning they maybe give you a
fine so anyway I did something stupid
but they brought the full weight of the
federal government down against me and
as a result of that I was incarcerated
overnight for eight months in a
confinement facility not if you were in
jail yeah I was in jail no no not a not
a normal prison but it's called a
confinement Center but yeah you can't
leave and I'm in a bunk bed it's just
like Danbury right I'm in a bunk bed
with like 60 hardened criminals get out
of here oh yeah so I did I did my eight
months I was done with all that I was
just in what year this was in 2000 uh
13. okay yeah and then um and then I'm
done with that but I'm still on
probation and I still you know like if I
travel like my passport gets dinged I
gotta go to a special room so my point
is I was still quote under scrutiny so
when Trump pardoned me I was doing
community service and I was on probation
but I've actually served my quote
sentence uh but the pardon cleared my
record I mean I can now vote I can own a
gun I mean had you ever been to jail
before in your life prior to that well
you I think you can imagine the answer
is obviously no okay here I mean no I
mean I didn't to me I was like yeah but
I don't know if you know now when he got
out he had an RNC tattoo here at 1776.
you want to show it to everybody
I mean even even the criminals knew I
mean they were like what are you doing
here and these conversations to me were
like laugh out loud funny because I'd be
like well you know I was I violated the
campaign Finance
campaign Finance law yeah so I go well
there's a campaign Finance is that like
carjacking I go you know I gave away too
much of my own money they're like pause
they're like you mean you didn't take
somebody else's money you're giving
money your money I'm like yeah you're
here for that they couldn't even believe
it so eight months so back to the Trump
pardon you he calls you you get a letter
and then like you get to uh yeah
communicate with him break that down he
calls me uh well Ted Cruz was the one
who asked him he goes you got a part in
Dinesh and literally Trump was like hmm
done it was like that wow yeah and then
Trump tells uh John Kelly who was then
the chief of staff you know work it out
now I didn't hear anything for 60 days
because they do a check they run a legal
review they do a few things but then Ted
Cruz calls me and he goes head in there
she goes you got your cell phone on you
he goes I got some interesting news he
goes the White House just called asking
for your phone number so you better keep
your cell phone like on on because
they're likely to call you in the next
like 60 minutes and you can't call them
back
so sure enough I got the call from Trump
and um and we talked for about 10
minutes on the phone he called you
personally yeah hey Dinesh yeah djt here
you know he uses his phone a lot he's
the guy that uses a smartphone that you
were getting out of jail all right well
he's also very casual he's like I'm here
with John Kelly he's like you know you
know John Kelly know you I'm like no I
mean I know he's the chief of staff but
I don't know General John Kelly General
John Kelly and then we know we talked a
little bit about the situation and he's
like Hey listen I'm gonna sign you a
pardon in the morning and but you know
the tweeting he goes he goes listen
don't tell anybody about it let me tweet
about it first he did say that and so it
was announced to the world via tweet of
course it was classic by the way it's
like a PR it's under embargo till
tomorrow yeah it's under embargo if
Trump was President how long would it
take him before Trump got Britney uh
Greiner out of uh Russia what do you
think well see this is the point is I
think I think that Trump would get on
the phone and be like let's lesson even
we were talking a little bit recently
about Ukraine and he's like look I don't
understand he's like the United States
is not using its leverage to make things
happen instead we're doing all these
other things that hurt ourselves like we
start suddenly start squeezing our own
energy Supply and then we got to go beg
energy from Maduro and Venezuela uh and
Iran and uh but no I think Trump the
thing about Trump is people think he's
an isolationist and he's not Trump
believes the United States should have a
strong place in foreign policy he just
thinks you got to think twice before you
commit troops you know if you go
throughout the Taliban in Afghanistan it
doesn't mean you have to rule
Afghanistan for the next 10 years that's
just Madness so in that sense he's
brought I think uh a new real politique
to the Republican Party an awareness of
of you know under Bush you had all this
nonsense like I think Colin Powell I
once heard him say something like well
you know it's like a restaurant where if
you break it you own it I'm thinking
nobody ever a set of more ridiculous
statement about foreign policy know if
you break it you don't own it if you
break it you just get the hell out of
there and let some other guys take over
I have a question
if we break and leave all the time I
just I have a question on Trump
obviously uh 2016 was a shocker right I
mean nobody expected that
um
you know if you follow the polls like
who are the most accurate polls you got
Pew you got a Quinnipiac you've got uh
what Marist Emerson College you go up
you got all these polls and then you
have like a little more biased polls
whether it's Fox CNN ABC what have you
um but I'll tell you the poll that uh is
the most credible the most credible by
far it's not even close and those are
the Vegas polls why because that's money
baby follow the money okay because you
might say that you know people have bias
and leanings but like Vegas they care
about their money so for instance you're
a golf guy right
that's your sport uh tennis okay oh
tennis I apologize golf tennis I
apologize but like for instance I'll
just use golf as an example if you want
to see who's going to win The Masters
you go on the site and Rory mcilroy's
favorite 1100 right then you got John
Ram you got Scotty sheffler Cameron
Smith cool got that then you've got even
president you can you know you can bet
on who's gonna win the President right
yeah you won't do time for that right
let's not have a good time for that
eight months not like six seven eight
with this baby so like right now I don't
know can you what is the what are the
numbers what are the odds of who wins
the 2024 election Trump they have they
have candidates
I'm trying to find uh yeah the odds are
right next to him I'm not sure yeah
Trump so trumpet at
the top so exactly but read the numbers
zoom in a little bit so Trump 320
DeSantis at 4 10. exactly uh Joe Biden
680 Newsome 1400 Harris 18. so my
question is this we can all agree that
Vegas doesn't want to lose money right
they want to put some on there twice by
the way that's what I was wondering yeah
okay Independence go ahead wait so my
question just to streamline this how
shocked were you that Trump lost the
election in 2020 how shocked were you
I was shocked okay I'll tell you why I
was not shocked and Pat will back me up
on this all I did I removed emotion from
the equation completely remove the
emotion and I just went on to all the
Vegas sites who do you think was favored
to win the 2020 election favored
who do you think was it Biden Biden was
favored correct on Vegas and and I did
this just to show this I don't know if
we could scroll I did a whole board
episode this was in Dallas you know how
much I love doing these board episodes
and I said before the election the Las
Vegas odds where Biden was 150 minus 150
to minus 180. Trump was plus 125 to plus
160. meaning if you bet a hundred bucks
on Biden you would win
-150 so you wouldn't even get your 150
bucks back however Trump if you bet 100
you'd win 125. so meaning Vegas had
Biden favored and you would think how
the hell is that but that those were the
odds so me removing emotion from the
equation we were in Dallas at this point
I bet everybody said name your amount
name your price I'm taking bets I said
I'm to and everyone bet on Trump I took
bite okay removing the motion from the
equation Pat bet a thousand dollars
someone else bet a thousand dollars
people were betting me lunches people
were betting me shirts to the point
where it was about ten thousand dollars
and I was like the bookie in Dallas okay
and other than Ricky everyone ended up
paying up because Trump in fact lost the
election again removing emotion if I'm
just going on Vegas odds followed the
money it was not that shocking because
Vegas had made Biden the favorite Trump
was not the favorite now you can factor
in covid you can factor in all the
reasons why you can factor in toxic
approval ratings what all that but just
removing emotion removing all the
pollsters Vegas doesn't like losing
money well let's let's explore that for
a second it's very fascinating to me and
let's apply generally let's say for
example now that you're talking about
the golf tournament right yes and you're
talking about these Vegas guys so I've
taken by and large are going to be
people who are golf fans who like to
watch golf and follow golf right now
let's say you have a separate group of a
hundred guys who are like top golfers
and these are people who are who know
the sport they they know the guys who
are playing they they know a lot about
them and you have them do this run you
run the same poll with those guys but
with no money involved they're not
putting any money in but they are let's
call them experts who know a lot about
golf
and and now you're deciding whether
you're gonna basically put your odds on
the Vegas guys or those guys you're
saying you'd pick the Vegas guys because
they're putting money on the table but
what makes you think they even know what
they're talking about well no I mean the
Vegas yeah they pick any sport NFL NBA
MLB like you can right right isn't there
a is there a World Series game tonight
you can go on right now and Vegas will
oftentimes like if you watch an NFL game
if the line is six I guarantee you the
team wins by seven that just happens
these guys are experts at odds this is
what they do there's no emotion you
think Vegas cared the Vegas odds makers
you think they cared if Biden or Trump
won I'm saying the odds makers they care
that they got their money so this is a
very good conversation the uh it's kind
of like you know the the two girls that
threw tomato soup against the van Gogh
painting a couple weeks we had them on
yeah we had them on the podcast two days
after they did that or three days after
they did that and the argument I made so
I said how concern are you about climate
change I said look it's not about people
us dying in 12 years people are dying
right now we're gonna we feel we're
gonna lose the right to age is the line
they use and I said listen just I'm in
the insurance industry actuaries are
sitting there saying you know we're
going to live up to 90 100 years old
you're going to be all right you're
going to live a long life because
insurance companies want to save money
right they don't want to pay that
additional money so the point you're
making about Vegas odds right before
election is something interesting to
entertain you know how did they know
well sure and and applying just
following the climate change logic you
know for example everyone's been saying
that the the coasts are going to get
flooded and so I say to myself you know
what if there's even a 10 chance that
over the next 20 years the coasts are
going to be flooded we should start
seeing a real drop of real estate prices
on the coast and perhaps a corresponding
rise relative rise of real estate prices
on the interior because your property is
now less safe on the coast yeah because
the climate change and so if real estate
prices on the Coast have been
indifferent and continue to go up then
it tells me that not just buyers and
sellers but real estate agents and
people who finance those properties are
not really worried this is going to
happen because their their economic
behavior doesn't show it
yeah going back but going back to it Tom
going back to it so with Vegas have an
art to say Biden was going to win it and
they got it right yeah that's why I was
shocked is what I'm saying is because
Vegas if if Vegas had Trump as a massive
favorite massive favorite he's gonna win
for sure for sure and then bite wins I'd
be like what just happened here but
essentially they gave Biden a a 20
chance to win like he was waiting what
was it for 2016 exactly can you go to go
to Hillary and Trump I'm actually
curious to know because now we got to go
back and look at the history but because
look shit's happened I mean it was 99.9
chance that in the second half of
Falcons against the Patriots they were
winning the Super Bowl and they came
back and won it 31-20 or whatever
of course yeah so come back so so can
you I'm actually curious at this point
what that Hillary looks like you know we
all know that even we I read every three
years in the Kentucky Derby that some
horse that has not favored to win comes
out of nowhere you go blows it away
there you go so so do you so it kind of
this also is more on you because here
they said minus 500 Hillary is going to
win a plus 350. but the only thing that
I will fact check this is what's the
date on that because we all remember
Hillary had a a pretty big lead a month
out and then if you were following the
race you'd saw it dwindle and dwindle
and then a week before the election
that's on November 7th day before so so
so I I uh so I'll say to you that Vegas
has gotten it wrong multiple times uh
because in this case Trump won in the
other case Trump lost so but but here's
here's the question about 2 000 mules
which was interesting yeah when when
typically typically okay so for example
if the midterms if if it's a sweep and
it's a bloodbath and it's like The
Shining when the elevator opens up like
when Rogan said that say it's that it's
the red wave
what's the likelihood that also that
affects Biden losing 2024.
repeat that okay so meaning meaning
if if if if that if the left's gonna
lose the house and maybe lose even the
Senate and a bunch of these Governors
there's all these things New York local
what are we talking about that chicken
potential very weird things that is
happening right now is that a sign of
the left or is that the sign of who they
have at the top that's not doing a good
job because the economy is not good
America is not in a good place so people
are saying listen man I'm flipping what
is that a reflection of I think that's
reflective of multiple things but
clearly the man at the top fair enough
so now here's the kicker this is the
part that made me think with the
documentary that they made when you guys
were talking do you realize even though
he lost
a lot of the other races people on the
right one you you know what I'm saying
so so the part that you kind of sit
there and you question things like right
now you made me think about it where I'm
like yeah that's right I guess Vegas
knew if Vegas known Obama Biden won why
are people still complaining about it
then we went and looked at Hillary okay
well then that's a different story
because we're digging we're probably
more shocking which Trump came out of
nowhere Hillary to be honest and we did
a podcast tonight with Trump we went to
sleep saying it's over Trump on with all
the numbers we were looking at next day
we're working up saying what What The
Hell Bound this line Flatline we were
all shocked the world was shocked but
going back to it how does Trump lose
that bad and everybody else he endorsed
did well that's that's a little weird
well it's a little weird there are two
possibilities and again you got to
consider the alternative right so here's
one possibility it could happen it could
happen this way you have all these
Suburban moms and they are right-leaning
and they have kids and they they are
concerned of what's going on with
schools and they're concerned with the
economy but they just got a little
annoyed at Trump's personality
particularly in the first debate Trump
was really irritable he was out of
control and they were like you know what
I'm done with this guy you know what
we'll give the other guys a chance
because Biden is a kind of a Centrist
he's not going to be that bad so there
is a possibility it could have happened
okay I'm not denying that and so my the
move that's not very likely that's a
very that's a very likely explanation
and in fact the it seems like the
Republican party is going to do a sweep
because all those people are now back
they have buyer's remorse they're like
listen we don't care about the tweets
man really hundred dollars to fill up my
car you know so what I'm getting is
that's that is a possibility now the
other possibility is this and that is
that if you are organizing an election
fraud operation it's a lot easier to do
against one guy than against 30 guys
because if you're running a multi paid
operation you got to go okay in Arizona
it's Kerry Lake and then okay we go it's
Blake Masters over here another guy over
here where's where you go listen Trump
is a menace Trump is like Hitler we got
to do everything we can to get rid of
trump we don't care what happens down
ballot we just have to fix what happens
at the top of the ballot and that was
that's another way to explain the result
and there's no reason to think that both
couldn't have been factors in 2020. so
with that being said how would that work
meaning like well a or any other
politicians claiming election fraud
either on the left or the right if they
lost other than Trump and Hillary and
Hillary I'm just saying for 2020. okay
like is is a is a senator from Maine
being like I should have won but they
screwed me is some representative of
Texas saying the exact same thing
because all you hear is Trump right
right nobody else down by down ballot
whatsoever so how does that work I mean
I've heard on the Republican side which
is basically where I've been hanging out
I've heard now I've been hanging out
I've been hanging out for Republicans
for for a decade a couple 20 years just
hanging out yeah he's hanging out but
what I'm saying is the sort of the word
on the street on the right side of the
street yeah is that we and I hear this
from candidates I heard from donors is
like we have to win cleanly because
they're gonna do some cheating and we've
got to make it that the margin is big
enough that even if there's cheating
we're still gonna win I mean this is
there's a there's a um there's a book by
Hugh Hewitt who is kind of a bit of a
not a never Trumper but certainly
someone closer to Liz Cheney than he is
to me and it's called it's essentially I
forget the title of the book but it's in
effect something like we gotta win big
enough so that the cheating won't matter
that's the title of the book so it's not
that this stuff is totally new uh it's
been going on uh but like I say what
happened in 2020 if you look at the
percentage of the absentee ballot vote
in let's say 2020 and compare it to say
2008 huge difference in 2008 absentee
ballots are I don't know maybe five
percent of the election and suddenly
they become 40 of the election well
because of Kobe because of covet right
but what I'm saying is there's an
anomaly it was no when I call it a Black
Swan event no but but what I'm saying is
that let's just say for example your
your a bank robber right and all the
banks have a lot of security and
suddenly they go because of covid we're
not going to have all these ATMs around
the country but nobody's going to be
policing them you go you know what I'm a
bank robber opportunity time let's hit
the ATMs because that's where they
haven't actually put up the safeguards
one more question with this is it fair
to say like I'm trying to think in the
future because I think it's fair to say
no matter what whatever documentary
opinion I mean barring some crazy
lawsuit legal allegation that comes out
there 2020 is done I mean we're about to
hit 2023 here buddy like so is it is it
more about trying to go backwards to
prove something or can we just prevent
BS and fraud and menacing in 2024 and
Beyond I mean my focus is totally on the
future you know in fact when people say
to me something like let's move on I say
to them of course I want to move on but
I think in order to move on it's kind of
helpful to know the truth about 2020.
I'm not trying to undo 2020 but I am
trying to use 2020 as an employee why
because a lot of the processes put into
place in 2020 have not been dismantled
so you'd think people would say okay
kovitz we're not getting over covered
let's go back to having by and large an
election day people show up they vote in
person buy paper ballots sure you have
exemptions for people in the military
people who are sick but let's go back to
the way but no one's saying that in fact
we still have long periods of early
voting we still have all these drop
boxes some of these states like
California have discovered you know
let's legalize ballot harvesting you
should be able to go to your church and
collect 400 ballots and go drop them all
off that's legal so what I'm getting at
is kovid was an opportunity to change
the rules and a lot of people are trying
to keep the new rules instead of saying
okay Cove it's over let's go back to the
old rule that's why the movie remains
relevant yeah but isn't the same isn't
that the exact same methodology of like
Hey look I get it I want to move forward
but we kind of got to address this isn't
that the same exact same methodology
with the January 6 committee it's like
yeah we would all like to move forward
with democracy sure but we kind of got
to address this January sixth
interaction thing same thought process
no yeah yeah I mean my objection to
January 6th is not that they're doing an
investigation but they're doing a show
trial under the guise of an
investigation right if they were doing a
real investigation then they'd have like
raps out there and they'd be like Mr
Epps I see a video of you telling people
to go inside the capitol but you haven't
been arrested do you have some kind of a
deal you made with the FBI are you are
you actually an informant or an agent
you know all these unanswered questions
are swept under the rug and so that's my
problem they're giving us the doctored
narrative and by the way same with Paul
Pelosi with Paul Pelosi though it's like
it's not that I'm unwilling to believe
that some crazy guy got into Paul
Pelosi's house and was and you know was
was threatening him or was trying to
harm him it's just that if you what
happened is they put out a narrative
right away this is what often happens
very similar to you know so most secure
election in history then suddenly some
facts come out and they look at the
facts and they go oh oh These facts
don't really fit this narrative we need
new facts
that like edited facts start coming out
and pretty soon then you go wait a
minute I don't think they're giving me
the full story and then they say and
this is just completing my thought on
Paul Pelosi yeah we do have video camera
footage and we do have body camera
footage and we have the recording of the
911
release any of those what do you
actually think happened with this Paul
Pelosi thing take off your you know
Republican you're hanging out with those
guys crew and just be a fact Checker
what do you actually think happened here
because the stories are so crazy and the
allegations are so the part is that's
concerning is that NBC changed the story
twice took a video down they put it up
it went down it's you know we can't talk
about that we're learning stuff no we
can't and then hey this is really you
know they're going after her and then
you know Nancy so a lot of uh a lot of
weird things going on there here's my
theory that would account for all the
facts as we know them now not even as we
know them at the beginning sure so you
got this wacky dude
he's a wacky okay he's a wacky dude and
and we can all agree also that sometimes
when you're uh mentally paranoid you
will pick up a grab bag of conspiracies
and wild ideas so this guy is a Berkeley
nudist he's lgbtq but he still thinks
the election was stolen so he he's not a
political you can't play some on the
Spectrum he's a paranoid right yes
somehow he figures out and I don't know
how he did this but he figures out how
to get into the Pelosi house right he
gets in I think what happens is because
he's a nut he starts engaging Paul
Pelosi right but he doesn't threaten him
he doesn't threaten him because that
explains the NBC report Paul Pelosi
comes to the door first of all Paul
Pelosi does not tell the cops he is
being attacked he doesn't say that he
says come do a wellness check on me
right he knows the guy's name he goes
the guy's name is David and he's a
friend now the left has been saying the
reason he said he's a friend is because
you know he had to he had to sort of get
on the good side of this guy but that
doesn't square with the fact that that
the guy let him do a bathroom break
where supposedly he was charging his
phone he wasn't with the guy he could
have told the cops anything but why'd he
let him in the house not only why do you
live in no the guy broke in my dead
break he did break in but but here's my
point you're in the bathroom a normal
person would lock the bathroom door
until the cop gets there right he didn't
do that he goes back out number two when
the cops show up apparently Paul Pelosi
lets them in and turns around and
returns to the house that's when the guy
attacks him so think about this no
normal person if you're in real fear the
guy threatened you I'm gonna smash your
head with a ham you would run out of the
door into the protection of the cops and
let them go in the house or so all of
this I think what happened with NBC is
they put this out and suddenly people
realize Paul Pelosi was not really
scared of this guy for whatever reason
and then they realized that doesn't fit
the narrative we got to take it down so
this is what I'm only all over this
because I hate to be like given a given
a story and then expect me to like just
take it because you said it but go
deeper some guy breaks into your house
right and I think Paul Pelosi was
sleeping it's 2 30 in the morning he's
in his underwear cool whatever right are
you not freaking out paranoid trying to
shoot the guy locking yourself like
what's this whole like by the way the
friend thing like how often do you say
like hey uh how's our friend doing how's
our friend and we're not he's not our
friend it's some guy we you know that
may be showing up like just for a
meeting hey our friend you use this term
a lot our friend hey how's our friend so
I'm kind of dismissing that but like if
some guy breaks in your house you're not
trying to talk to this guy you're not
getting buddy buddy you you're freaking
out what the [ __ ] you're doing to my
house like what is this exchange that
they're actually having I think that and
I only say this because I mean it's kind
of funny yesterday I was at the airport
right and I'm just waiting to pick up my
bags and literally this Hasidic guy
comes up to me and starts like really
engaging me in intense conversation and
not sort of like hey didn't actually
like your work or something like that
but he starts talking to me about in the
Hasidic Community he goes we started
growing vegetables on my on my balcony
and he says have you are you familiar
with the Hasidic newspaper I'm like no
you know I'm not Hasidic you know so
what I'm getting at is is there are a
lot of cooks right and and you can
pretty well in a in almost a moment pick
up if someone is just a nut right and
they want to like and and when someone
is in the political domain you get
approached by lunatics by the way there
are plenty of lunatics on the right and
on the left yeah and they're always
handing you material they want you to
take with you they're always in my case
proposing movies I I ought to make they
always want to tell me about their life
story in some cases they think they're
being followed or the FBI is after them
so I think it's something like this this
guy was an animated Kook and he get in
he gets it now Paul Pelosi admittedly
he's not well he is over 80. so he's an
old man but I think what happened is he
he recognized right away this is the
kind of [ __ ] that Nancy and I have been
dealing with for much of them
exactly and so on for the course yeah I
better I better see if some cops will
come by make sure I'm okay yeah I think
at that point he was clearly not under
attack because the attack is at least as
far as we know occurred when the cops
were there yeah but it's so weird
because we've all been approached by
random people you're trying to get out
of it you're trying to be nice but
you're also kind of like kind of got to
keep it moving like the Hasidic guy at
the airport that's cool right I mean
you're trying to but this is in your
house at three in the morning
that's so weird to me why you'd be
friendly or whatever kind of atmosphere
I don't know it's not something's not
adding up I mean I still don't know why
the cops didn't shoot the guy because I
don't even mean shoot to kill him but
just at least shoot to disarm him
because if you see a guy with a hammer
hitting Paul Pelosi on the head you
would think you would use Force
immediately and and you'd use lethal
Force but also you're the you're the
number three in line to the presidency
Nancy Pelosi right right okay she was in
DC I believe at the point so she wasn't
even home but you're the husband hot as
some kooky dude break into your compound
you know you know we talk about Build
That Wall are you kidding me hardly how
did he get in
unanswered unknown weird can we read two
articles I'm sending you one of them uh
that's coming your way but let me read
this one this is MB this is CNN NBC News
pulls uh report on papalosi's attack NBC
news on Friday pulled a report about the
Pelosi attack uh that the network did
not meet the standards the peace should
not have aired because it did not meet
NBC's news reporting standards and
editors said uh in place of storyline
the package from National correspondents
Miguel made assertions that were
attributed to on a unnamed sources and
appear to raise questions about the
circumstances of the attack a network
source told CNN it pulled the segment
after the source of the reporters
information was found to be unreliable
the decision was not made was made to
remove the segment afterwards determined
shortly after the rare that the main
source for the information was
unreliable regarding the questions of
circumstances that the police
encountered when they aired at the house
especially specifically what the police
saw and how far the attacker was from
the door okay I mean that's kind of
weird for NBC to do that and then
Reuters wrote this which is kind of
weird for Reuters even writers fact
Checkers existing records do not show
Paul Pelosi's alleged attacker David
told investigators they engage in sexual
relations and argued over drugs
interesting to even put this up there
for Reuters some social media users are
saying that David the suspect in the 20
October 20 attack on Paul Pelosi told
mosquitoes at the two engage in sexual
relations over our drugs without
providing proof of claim however there
is no publicly available evidence that
debate the baby made these statements to
officials one Twitter user sharing the
claim said David tells investigators
that he and Paul were engaging in gay
sex and an argument in suit over drugs
and but official records and statements
do not support the claim uh that uh the
baby told the investigators he was
engaged in sexual relation with policy
the husband of U.S speaker and it's okay
so so this is this is this is what's
spreading right now and Don Lemon uh
somebody was telling the story Donald
was like I can't believe they're doing
this and uh you know this some people
are saying this was really going on
they're trying to hide this from the
public well look I mean the reason that
this the sex thing started was there was
a report by Fox 10. now this is not by
the way the Fox News Channel this is not
a right wing so this is the local Fox
reporting station and a reporter who's
in San Francisco in San Francisco yes
Fox 10 in San Francisco and the local uh
report are covering the story very
reliable guy said that not only was Paul
Pelosi in his underwear but so was the
attacker think about this from it yeah
so you're thinking wait a minute Paul
Pelosi in his underwear okay he's his
house it's 2 A.M in the morning he's
sleeping you're sleeping in a suit and
tie of course you're in underwear but
the idea that the attackers in his
underwear was like whoa what the hell's
going on there so that's what started
leading to the idea that this was some
kind of Rendezvous that went sideways or
something then they corrected that they
said oh that's not the case he wasn't in
his underwear so as far as I know this
thing got dropped the sex thing got
dropped right and stopped talking about
it now the NBC thing is more telling
because if you look at the NBC report
and the guy is obviously not trying to
get Pelosi or get he's he's just
reporting right he makes two points that
are damaging first of all he says that
when when when Paul Pelosi came to the
door and the and and met the cops
instead of exiting the the apartment he
turned around and returned to the quote
scene of the crime where he was then
attacked and that right away raises the
question that was Paul Pelosi even did
he even feel threatened by this guy if
not why would you walk back into his
vicinity and the second thing they said
was that even though the police were at
the Pelosi residence
they didn't know it was Pelosi's
residence they didn't even know it was
Nancy Pelosi's husband so in other words
it'd make them look like idiots so so
the NBC report was damaging to the cops
and it was damaging to Paul Pelosi and
so that's my point is is my question is
when NBC doesn't meet our standards is
that they don't meet your standards of
Truth or they don't meet your standards
of not fitting The Narrative and the
Pelosi's look bad and therefore you took
it down can you pull up the windows can
you pull up the glass window shatter
just type in glass window Paul Pelosi
click on images there's there's one
thing that's a little weird uh when you
look at this go click on it and uh go to
go to zoom in zoom in on that one the
one that you have the one that you just
okay that one right there if someone's
breaking in when you break the window
and you hit it glass goes the other way
why is glass coming out
do you get what I'm saying so I don't
just make sense what I'm asking go on
another picture maybe we can have a
better angle like if I'm trying to break
into a house that's a CSI question yeah
so if I'm breaking into a house and I'm
cracking and look I'm a military guy but
I'm not a CSI guy if I hit the window
with the hammer to break in class should
go in not out
but why is it coming out it's got a
little weird so where are you going with
that maybe the guy was trying to get out
from Paul I got to get out of here
I'm not saying he's trying to get up I
can't see how much glasses on the inside
there's only a little bit of Glass on
the outside I don't know where the glass
thing I'll tell you what upsets me
there's like this this is where like
rumors and conspiracy theories kind of
go down a rabbit hole Dinesh
okay let's say they're both under
something freaking weird this guy's 82
years old he's married to Nancy for the
God for five decades now there's zero
stories out there correct me if I'm
wrong for the last 50 years he's been in
the public eye that he's at any weird
sexual gay stuff Tendencies any of that
and you're gonna wait till you're 82
years old a week before midterms with
some [ __ ] delusional guide that's
where you're gonna seize the moment to
do a little sword fighting and it seems
so weird to me
maybe it's just now breaking you know
you've not been married to Nancy Pelosi
for five days it's not like he's married
to Melania Trump right Nancy the point
is do you do you give any any
credibility to this gay sex story no I
don't now
um when I first heard the double
underwear story I was like hmm that's
interesting look let me let me put it
this way I think that this story is
coming at a time when people have
developed a deep distrust of our public
institutions
yeah and it happens slowly but it's it's
now very far Advanced people don't
believe the media I think with with a
lot of justification they don't believe
the FBI no they don't they only believe
their media they believe their media
okay they don't believe the other side
they only believe their side yeah they
don't but they don't trust the CDC I
mean they're up you know you can't trust
scholarly journals these days think
about it journalists like the Lancet
have admitted this is the most
prestigious medical journal in the world
has admitted that they have published
doctor data that they have known things
were false and published them because
they quote serve the public good you
know these you have these top scientists
saying we we don't know we're not
involved of gain of function research
turns out that they do know they are
involved uh you know they're making
these deadly viruses and we knew nothing
about it for over a year even after
covid you know
um then they never seriously consider
where this virus comes from so suddenly
people look at this and again now
they're in the past you'd have a San
Francisco police chief this is what
happened and they'd be like yeah okay
that's what happened you know and and I
was like that too I mean because science
has even got politicized these days and
we've all trusted science trusted
science then you see what's happened
with covid or even like global warming
and it's like I will say I will say this
when you say stuff like he's never had
anything in the past stuff like that the
guy just got a DUI like a few weeks ago
I mean you're talking about an 82 year
old guy that just got a DUI
I'd love to know what is the oldest DUI
in the history of America can you pull
it up like who is the oldest person ever
did he he deserves the right to be in a
Guinness Book of World Records
no no if you're acting irresponsibly
lately so if you're saying the guy
doesn't have a track record you have a
track record of just a few weeks ago
getting a DUI yes you are acting
irresponsibly that doesn't mean the
sword fight I'm not talking about that
yeah but all I'm saying to you is the
track record is recent you've been
acting irresponsibly getting a DUI well
you know where I stand on DUIs I feel
like you should be like fully Uber lived
yeah just like these days if you get a
DUI especially that's a different
discussion let's not get sidetracked but
my point is all I'm saying has nothing
to do with no underwear
sexy no no you said does he have a track
record
I'm not saying gayness I'm telling you
being irresponsible okay being
irresponsible he has a track record of
being a response doubt he has a track
record responsible for the stocks that
they're doing there's so many things he
doesn't have the biggest moral Authority
and credibility right now but let's get
past this story let's get past the story
hopefully the the right people will do
enough due diligence and research and
we'll find out what's going on here and
we'll get to the bottom of it and I by
the way I I even think it's a non like
who cares but it's like what are you
doing like it's it's one of those
stories for me I do want to talk about
it one thing here so Obama's getting
heckled at Arizona okay rallying uh
while you know he's uh stomping for the
Democratic candidates I'm gonna read the
story to you and you know Katie Hopps is
going up against the lake and Katie
Hopps was the other day asked by uh Don
Lemon on his latest show that's crushing
it they asked they asked the question
about uh why are you laughing his
ratings came back it was true so more
recipes with Don Lemon Don Lemon asks a
question saying to which by the way I
actually like the fact that he did this
right him and his panel asked Katie hop
saying hey just out of curiosity why are
you choosing not to debate Lake I don't
want to choose to debate Lake because I
don't want to give it a platform for her
to spew her lies and all this other
stuff and you know what lemon set which
is power to him and his crew he says
yeah okay I think the girl asked him
says I I get that but you also Dodge
debating your Democratic opponent for
governor and you also didn't debate your
opponent says well you realize why
because I won it's like well yep you put
your dodging debates there's not a lot
of credibility when you're dodging
debates but this story so Obama's up
there he's getting heckled on Wednesday
during the rally in Phoenix where
Democrats in Arizona Obama was stumping
for Mark Kelly and Katie Hopps who are
respectively in close races for Senate
and governor and talking about the
economic impact and coronavirus pandemic
had on American families and communities
when he was interrupted by Heckler the
pandemic also highlighted and in a lot
of cases made worse problems that we've
been struggling within four years an
economy that's very good for folks at
the very top which that's where he is
but not always so good for ordinary
people like you Obama the Heckler
shouted before uh
being booed by the crowd hold up hold up
Obama said young man just listen for a
second you have to be polite and civil
when people are talking then other
people are talking and then you get a
chance to talk set up your own rally a
lot of people worked hard for this come
on man so okay so that's that right fine
this is the interesting part I got a
question for everybody in the audience
including yourself
do you know how many followers Obama has
on Twitter
do you know the number give or take how
many followers you think he's got on
Twitter don't pull it up I'm just asking
we'll pull up here in a minute guessing
yes
50. Trump's got 100 right 50 million
he's got 133 million wow okay now do you
realize when Obama was on fire and he
was tweeting anything is it fair to say
he's the face of Democrats he carries
the most weight for Democrats is that is
that fair to say absolutely you mean
other than Biden today or no Biden's
numbers are dismal there's a reason why
Obama's campaigning not Biden to help
the Democrats Biden's not campaigning
okay so is it fair to say he's the voice
of the left is it fair to say that okay
fair enough so if if he tweets
encouraging people to go out there and
vote on 133 million followers how many
people should like his tweet
just asking a question just a couple
million a couple men should like his
tweets easily okay let's say a million
people have to like that's two to four
percent let's go to his Twitter account
let's see how much the Democrats are
excited about what Obama's been saying
go to Obama Twitter account hopefully
this uh you don't have to go fully down
and you know uh uh uh all right so if
you go there zoom in a little bit okay
so he's got 133 million followers great
so pin tweet to the top that's that's
his anniversary
570 000 likes fantastic that's a month
ago okay here's two minutes ago we can't
count that because it's only two minutes
432 likes gosh 19 hours ago the only way
to make democracy stronger is we fight
for it and this starts by electing so
vote for Democrats only 48 000 likes on
133 million
followers golod lower Gola lore look at
this next one here okay 5700 likes next
one while he's in Arizona pictures it
should be high
Adam 14 000 likes go to the next one I
will vote 37 this is the former two-term
president Superstar Democrat with 133
million followers go to Biden's account
because he says well it's it's got to be
Biden like just go up a little bit
you'll see by no no don't do that just
go up it'll be Biden just go up go up go
up go up go up go up keep going up keep
going up keep going up click on biting
right there yeah there you go go on
Biden he's got 27 million followers
let's see how he's doing let's see how
much his team is excited about him watch
this October 6th
as I've said before no one should be in
jail for using or possessing marijuana
today I'm taking steps to end our failed
approach allow me to lay them out okay
cool guess what with marijuana most
people don't like both sides cool we're
chilling we're good 682. now go to the
next one 4200 go to the next one 40
million Americans stand for student debt
relief 11 000 likes that's the current
president by the way go to the next one
uh uh keep going down keep going down
okay that's six thousand likes next one
jobs are up domestic products so so this
is a picture that should be reassuring
okay beautiful picture it's a nice light
it's in the chair they got smoke there
somebody should have fixed this tight
it's a little bit to the right but it's
fine nice shoes 33
000
33 000 likes you know what this tells
you
if if your own base isn't excited about
you man you don't Inspire them and you
got a 133 million 27 million followers
look you lost your you lost your
audience you've lost your audience
celebrities go through it athletes go
through it you go look at Bad Bunny
right now when you post something on
Instagram you know how many likes Bad
Bunny yes right now 10 million likes on
fire on fire maybe Bad Bunny should run
for president on the left right but not
American the moral of the story the
moral of the story is this
they've lost their voice with their own
people when you lose your own people you
you panic on the way you're talking the
other day somebody I don't know who was
it that said these next few days this
could determine whether our kids can
even write a book 40 years from now oh
and they're even lives they could even
get killed did you yeah because you know
what this was the historian Michael
beschlas and what's particularly amazing
is that this is this guy was at least
used to be a well-respected presidential
historian but one of the most of course
and then you look at even Biden's speech
this is how I read Biden's speech
because Biden's speech is like this
midterm election is about an attack on
Democracy right and think about what
he's saying what he's basically saying
is we have two parties in America a
Republican party and a Democratic party
one of those two parties is basically
illegitimate because it is the party
that is against democracy the other
party my party uh Biden's party is for
democracy and so what he's basically
telling the American people is in the
midterm election even if you don't like
the Democrats even if you don't agree
with their values even if you don't
agree with their policies you should
vote for them why because they stand for
democracy so what he's saying without
really saying it is he's kind of saying
we only have a one-party state
there's only one legitimate party in the
United States which think about it I
mean that's basically Iran right you
have one party yes we'll have some
candidates we'll have some token
opposition list they said there's Fair
election but it's not right yes in
effect you're saying that the American
people do not have two options before
them that are both legitimate and they
can choose which direction they want the
kind so the anti-democratic rhetoric is
really coming from the Democratic side
and I've seen nothing equivalent in the
Republicans die in fact they keep saying
you have all these people who've said
that they will deny the result of the
2022 election I've never heard anyone
say that I've never heard a single
person say I'm denying in advance the
result of the 2022 election the only
person who said that is Hillary and
Hillary is talking nonsense because
she's actually talking about a Supreme
Court case coming up this fall this is
what Hillary is getting on by the way
she says extremists are going to rig the
2024 election who are the extremists the
Supreme Court and how are they
extremists because there's a case before
them coming up in this fall this fall
about whether election rules should be
made by legislature state legislatures
or judges or officials like the
Secretary of State who decides how an
election let's say in Wisconsin should
be run who has the final say well the
Constitution tells you it's the state
legislature it's in the Constitution
that's up before The Supreme Court
Hillary saying that if the Supreme Court
decides what the Constitution says that
the final Authority is with the state
legislature that is how we're going to
rig the 2024 election so just think
about that it's just downright insanity
and she she doesn't get canceled for it
she's allowed to say that she's
celebrated how do you feel about Moscow
and Twitter by the way how do you feel
about the whole concept of mosque by
Twitter and he lost all these
advertisers I think musk lost two
yesterday he lost General uh GM he lost
Pfizer he lost uh Audi he lost a bunch
of guys he said every day we're losing
how much money they says Twitter's
losing 4 million dollars a day some
number like that he tweeted yesterday
that they're losing four million dollars
a day and it's unfair that this is
happening uh right there Toyota has a
massive drop in Revenue due to activist
groups Russian advertisers even though
nothing has changed in the content
moderation and we did everything we
could to piece the active is extremely
messed up they're trying to destroy free
speech in America and then later on he
says that they're losing four million
dollars a day but how do you feel about
the fact that he's buying Twitter well
let me buy Twitter let me tell you what
I saw today that really encouraged me go
to go to a guy on Twitter his name is
Mike Davis and he tweets out to Elon
Musk and he basically says that
um he has a solution to this Advertiser
problem and it comes back to Twitter
followers so go down to Mike Davis
replying to Elon Musk
uh and then Elon Musk replied to Davis
today
uh
uh okay he goes um let me see if you can
find it um
I think that's it uh one second yeah
there we go there we go
um can you zoom in
no no that's not it keep going keep
going down
um
man these days people tweet a lot so
it's not so easy to find is it a reply
or is it a tweet give me a second yeah
you know what and then I'll go I just
found a dear Elon Musk you have 140
million Twitter followers is that the
one that's it name and shame the
advertisers who are uh succumb
succumbing to The Advertiser boycotts so
we can counter boycott them and get your
eight dollars a month monthly
subscription go on ASAP so we can start
to make up for losses of Revenue and
then read elon's reply
responds back
uh uh I actually don't see his reply I
only see his I don't see what Elon said
okay
um what did Elon say basically Elon goes
oh there you go thank you a thermal uh
thermonuclear name and Shane is exactly
what will happen if this continues right
so this tells me that Elon Musk
recognizes that there is a big battle
over free speech in America and the
question becomes I mean he brings
incredible resources to it what I didn't
know is does he bring the will to fight
this out because these people are
determined to protect the regime of
censorship and he's so I'm very high on
Elon Musk I think it's fantastic that he
bought Twitter
um Twitter has suddenly become a free
speech platform for the most part even
though Elon says our moderation policies
haven't changed I think the word is out
that this is now a free speech platform
and see that puts pressure now on
YouTube and Facebook because because in
the free market of big platforms versus
censorship platforms it's hard for me to
see censorship platforms winning long
term so they they're able to agree they
are able to win if they can all
coordinate with each other so you don't
have an alternative just like you can
make your product successful you just
lost the big one though exactly they
just lost the big one by losing Twitter
right so they can't now that's all come
together by the way you know what I told
them yesterday I said to Elon when he
was saying this I tweeted back I said
you're the right guy for the job I said
the hate you got with Tesla got you PhD
in handling hate the hate you're about
to get with Twitter will earn you your
own planet and that's that's what's
going because he's about to get it times
a thousand right endless go ahead Tom no
you've seen things like this it's like
you take a look at OPEC OPEC worked in
the 70s even in the 80s but then all it
took was one which was usually oh man or
UAE to be shipping oil at night you
remember these days and they broke from
OPEC and the Venezuela broke from OPEC
and then OPAC was was sort of a general
pricing arm they were not a supply arm
anymore remember those days and so I
think right now the supply and the
pricing so social media has been I I
think has been not in the lock step but
it's been together and I think it's
fracturing everywhere and also Facebook
doesn't have the new generation Facebook
has its own problems of long-term
relevancy without worrying about
censorship in my view
and with with Rumble you now have a real
alternative to YouTube so YouTube is
still much bigger but rumble's been
growing well and so the game is changing
under Free Speech Chris is the right guy
at the top by the way did you hear about
what uh Bank of England warned of
yesterday Bank of England warns of
longest recession in 100 100 years as it
raises rates to three percent
uh that's not very much of an optimistic
message coming from the bank of England
three quarters of a basis point increase
the latest in a series of eight interest
rate hikes since last year would not be
enough to guarantee victory in a war
against double legit inflation the bank
of England said as a cautioned further
action would be needed the UK economy
faces a very challenging Outlook with a
recession that began this summer now
expected to last the middle of 2024 with
the possibility of a general election
being held in 2024 the conservatives
face campaigning to remain in government
at the tail end of a prolonged slum
during which the bank said it expected
unemployment rates to rise from three
and a half to six and a half percent so
and if they're saying that double that's
going to happen here as well next year
in unemployment we're not there yet
though so but Tom what does that mean if
Bank of England is saying this well I
think what you see here at the bank of
England is you have a Frank assessment
of what is actually happening in our
economy we there you know they say oh
don't call it a recession we're not
going to do that we're going to change
the definition look what's going on over
here we're already seeing the interest
rates raise we've already had the
multiple uh multiple UPS we're seeing we
were just talking about the jobs report
that the jobs report was really talking
about low-end jobs that the 10.7 million
was low-end jobs what you're seeing
there you know know that is uh that is
exactly what is happening here we're
just not willing to to say it
we're just now willing to say it we're
not willing to say it yeah it's the
things like things yeah I mean I think
that um again I hope my mind flashes
back to the in the in the in the late
80s 90s we had this profession called
the economics profession and you had
economists on the left and on the right
but they weren't all that far apart on
the facts they disagreed about sometimes
their interpretation they would disagree
for example on the effect of inflation
on interest rates
um but there was a lot of inflation by
the way this word Republican's been
using lately what is the do you guys
know the meaning of uh Tyler what does
this mean Joy Reid said republi you know
people some a lot of people don't know
what this word inflation means can you
pull up the definition if I have to
interrupt you because some of us are not
from America here I was born in Iran
what is the definition of inflation go
to definition of inflation because
apparently only the folks on the left
know what the meaning of inflation is in
economic in relations increases in the
price of goods and services in an
economy got I just want to verify that's
our audience knows that but go ahead
right I mean the key thing about
inflation is that you have the same
number of goods that then cost more
across the board and that's that's
inflation uh because because essentially
what it means is your money is losing
value right so for example if you have a
hundred dollars in your pocket and you
can buy a hundred dollars worth of stuff
and there's ten percent of inflation in
effect you now have 90 in your pocket
even though you still count a hundred
that's the point of what inflation is
and and uh but what I was saying was
that this body of economic knowledge
appears to have almost vanished and I
don't know if it's because the
economists are now muted and their
influence is reduced but suddenly you
have I think with the Biden
Administration or regime that doesn't
seem to pay any attention to economic
information and at least in the old
sense you think it's in their top five
list of concerns on a daily basis
economics no
I don't know I think uh if a president
doesn't make the economy at the top of
their issue it's just a pathetic move a
president can make and who would look at
the way he deals with his his idea of
bringing gas prices down is essentially
releasing all the oil in the Strategic
Reserve
and so his point is and even with the
Saudi artificial Supply Spike that he
does which now limits the um options
that he would have to handle a real
energy crisis and then and then his
second move which failed but but was
again very Insidious a secret agreement
with the Saudis to temporarily increase
oil production for three months till he
got over the midterms so they he they
were fine to then go back to their old
policy it's to give him an artificial
electoral boost that's 15 for the big
guy
wow this is the times nonetheless this
is the New York Times Yes U.S officials
had a secret oil deal with the Saudis or
so they thought after Saudi leader
pushed to slash oil production despite a
visit by President Biden American
officials have been left fuming that
they were duped
that's pretty embarrassing that New York
Times writes that that's what happens
when you call the Saudis pariahs and
then you try to cut a deal with them on
oil they have all the leverage here what
do you expect to happen
this is the great Point basically Biden
was implying that Muhammad bin Sultan
the prince of the Crown Prince of Saudi
Arabia is a murderer so you go around
saying that and then he's the guy you
have to go to to cut this deal right did
you see well he is murder I mean he
definitely gave the order for the uh
khashoggi Tyler I tweeted something at
you really later
you know what I'm talking about I sent
something to you last night at the like
the nearly 11 o'clock I don't know what
time it was pull this tweet up it's such
a funny tweet if you can pull it up okay
so check this out New York Times as the
midterm elections nears President Biden
has increasingly made uh uh exactly
exaggerations and wait a minute they
changed the Tweet they no they did an
exaggeration misstatements about his
influence on the US economy and his
policy record look at the title on that
article as elections approach Biden
spins his economic record New York Times
by the way this is the profit this is by
the way I went just to read the comments
okay so go below it and read some zoom
in a little bit uh look what they say
now did you say the same or as much
about the former president I don't
remember seeing it yeah like New York
Times didn't go after Trump 50 times a
day uh uh keep going keep going to the
bottom keep going to the bottom you'll
see someone to stutter democracy could
be it's in its death Thrones and this is
is where you focus your attention on New
York Times if you haven't already done
so cancel your subscription so the left
is now cancel because they printed truth
I'll buy it for once
because Biden's going around
untrustworthy rag that's an exaggerating
for missing anything it's fish wrap I
tell you yeah it was and by the way did
you see uh the the Newsome yesterday
tweeted something out uh uh I don't know
if you saw my response to Newsome I love
what uh he's getting a little frustrated
too yeah let me sent you what I if you
just go to mine you'll see uh both of
them here I'll just text it to you I
just texted you which is so funny
because the way he tried to spin
California yesterday it's like a great
place to be there you go right there so
he says on the bottom life in blue
States lower murder rates lower gun
death uh rates
longer life expectancy higher GDP higher
minimum wage don't believe the GOP lies
and I said life in California higher
utility and gas pricing in America
highest poverty rate highest income tax
highest housing costs highest
homelessness you lost musk Rogan
Hollywood and soon Twitter headquarters
bad policies have consequences you know
but they say that and and some people
are sitting there saying that's right
and did you see when they pulled up
matter of fact I think we even did it
this Tuesday on the podcast or Thursday
when we pulled up the top cities in
America with murder rate and I think I
don't know what the number was like well
St Louis had recently passed Detroit
yeah they're pretty competitive in that
area and uh although Detroit's upset
about it and they'll be back on top in
no time yeah I mean it's it's uh I mean
this is a case I I actually wish the
Republican candidates did more with this
kind of thing because I find I mean I
travel a lot uh generally to speak and
so you take us take you know Tennessee
you go to Nashville which is by and
large a democratic city right away you
see it's very dangerous Memphis by the
way the same can't walk out on the
street
um it's trash everywhere homeless
everywhere then you go to Chattanooga
which is just a couple of hours away by
driving
republican-leaning City on the Georgia
border totally different very beautiful
landscapes there's a huge Bridge you
look under the bridge there's not one
guy lying on a homeless guy bear
um you can walk around pretty safely
this is a kind of a festive atmosphere
in the evening people going to
restaurants so there's a there's a
noticeable difference depending on who's
running a city of what that City looks
like Tom you and I had a call yesterday
with the owner of one of the largest
magazines in the world we won't name it
and the the owner had moved from a uh
from a California to uh Boise Idaho I
think not in Boise Idaho but something
it was in Idaho and I said so what is
high-end zip code in California we won't
name it right very high-end I said I
said what's the what's the uh safety
like in Idaho it says well in Idaho you
can carry a gun with a driver's license
so in Idaho if you get a driver's
license you have the right to carry okay
and if you look at Idaho's numbers it's
unbelievable where they rank the amount
of people that murder all of those stats
in Idaho very very low and you can carry
there which is the driver's license and
the only reason I'm saying this because
he's thinking about moving to Boise
Idaho yeah nightlife is amazing they're
ten times better than Miami you can't
compare California to Idaho though right
hey it takes the fun out of an ATM
telling you how there's a one in three
chance you're gonna get offed
just can't tell you anything uh but
anyway so he moved to Idaho and uh
you're hearing a lot of stories like
that I mean Julia Roberts moves to
Nevada Mark Wahlberg is moving to Nevada
that's very weird Julia Roberts just
came out with a story
I think her book is coming out and she
told the story about how Martin Luther
King helped her parents when they were
going through financial needs I don't
know if you saw that story or not no
real interesting story that was kind of
cool me and you were talking about it
anyways uh uh uh Dinesh before we wrap
up is there anything you're working on
that you want to share with the audience
obviously we're going to put the link
below to 2000 meals I think it can be
found on locals right it's it's a is
it's on locals it's also on the platform
called Salem now and of course DVDs you
can get DVDs in Amazon and elsewhere and
I have a book of the same title 2000
meals but they finally allow you to
publish it because I know it was like a
challenge you were having it was delayed
it's out now and I think what's new with
life since I last saw you is I'm now
doing a daily podcast it's kind of fun I
do an hour a day and it's an audio and
video all the usual places Apple Spotify
Google and then Rumble and YouTube for
the uh rumble on YouTube for the video
what's the name of the podcast it's just
called the Dinesh D'Souza podcast okay
let's put the link below as well so they
can find them Dinesh thanks for coming
coming out gank we don't normally do a
Saturday Morning podcast but Dinesh was
here we said let's figure out a way to
do podcasts together uh have a great
weekend Dinesh once again thanks for
coming out always a pleasure guys thank
you everybody bye-bye bye-bye